e
open the committee meeting of children
and family law for Tuesday March 4th a
few announcements before we go to our
first hearing um we've all very sadly
watched the no longer avalability of
Girl Scout cookies through
representative LC but there is good news
uh uh there is a
connection and it's on the fourth floor
and of course we want to go up to the
fourth floor front desk and buy some
Girl Scout cookies wouldn't you say so
we've fixed that problem the second ly
for the uh minority if you are going to
be filing a Minority Report it has to be
in today this is something that we were
reminded of in uh chair's meeting just
now uh it goes on the Green Sheet the
statement of oh we're still thinking
about it can we be back to you in a few
days the answer is no if we do not have
the desire of a Minority Report and the
person writing it by the time we leave
today there will not be one the Green
Sheet has to reflect
it
um there will be no meeting of this
committee next Tuesday we were told as
much as possible we should not be
meeting next Tuesday because it's town
meeting day and that affects many of us
in various ways you will see on the
calendar there are a few committees that
are meeting they have 6 or 70 or 80
bills they're dealing with so given the
choice of our meeting next week and
having 80 bills or are not meeting next
week and not having 80 bills I opted for
we're not meeting next
week our next committee committee
meeting will be in two weeks from today
March 18th and on the agenda of that
meeting will be everything that's on our
plate before crossover there will be
hearings and executive sessions
on HB 518 requiring the commissioner of
DHHS to provide a detailed annual report
of all costs incurred by
DCF and there will be a hearing and
executive session on
775 directing DHHS to issue a request
for proposals for supervised visitation
centers with our own representative
Nelson as Prime Representatives D Simon
and rice amongst the co-sponsors and as
a co-sponsor our occasional substitute
representative and law professor buz
sure we must exact those bills the same
day now because crossover looms nigh
offering uh also an executive session is
553 which a lot of people have done a
lot of work on um today's acting ranking
member Alicia greay is the prime and I
count eight additional members of this
committee as co-sponsor a lot of work
has been
done um representative acting ranking
member do we have an update on
representative otherwise Deputy ranking
member Grossman's son uh things still
pretty much remain the same so he is
still in the piku at Mass General so um
prayers and good thoughts still needed
um they hanging in there so got it thank
you like to introduce uh
substitutes uh representative would you
tell us who you are where you're from
and what committee you're usually on
before your promotion to us thank you Mr
chairman it's actually a demotion and
less work because I'm usually the clerk
on Judiciary I'm Katie peternell state
representative for wolfboro thank you do
you realize that we have two clerks to
do the clerk job here so I'll I'll take
one anytime
and representative Greg tell us who you
brought so we have uh representative
Rosemary rang do you want to introduce
yourself sure thank you um Rosemary rung
I represent Hillsboro 12 which is the
town of marac and I typically uh sit on
division one of Finance so this is kind
of a a nice change I've never subbed in
ch ch children and family law and I'm
starting my fourth term I won't say
which I won't say which division of
finance good bills go to die I will say
it is not division one yeah it's going
to be a brutal year yeah thank you for
being here we also have Stephanie rund
right grund thank you I'm Stephanie
grund and I represent Hillsboro 34 which
is amst and I usually sit on Municipal
and County government and this is my
first term so it's my first time subbing
so I'm excited to be here and I just
want to say thank you for supporting
Girl Scouts I was a girl scout leader
for two troops and SP and worked on many
events in town as the accounting leader
so did you bring a stash with you today
I have lots of access if you need access
okay fourth floor front desk but now we
have another Connection in
case and then one uh final thing before
we begin
um I will be appointing uh a family
court subcommittee of this children and
family law committee two years ago the
Speaker of the House asked me to chair a
special committee on the Family Division
of Circuit Court four members were
appointed by me from this committee and
in consultation with me chairman Lynn of
the Judiciary Committee appointed five
people from his committee we took 12
hours of oral testimony received volumes
of written communication and had
numerous meetings of the committee and
subcommittees because many individuals
hold a highly negative view of our
courts I wanted to assure our Judicial
System leaders that in general the way I
address issues is collaboratively not
confrontationally and would act that way
with them that is to say unless or until
I am convinced otherwise I would be of
the belief that our judicial leaders
come to work each day to do the best
they can and to be fair and to be
hopeful of course there is the
occasional bad judge just as the
occasional bad apple is to be found in
every
profession but my offer to the judicial
leaders that I wish my special committee
to gang up with them against
problems and not to gang up against them
they were of the same opinion our two
years of work proved this to be true we
started with lwh hanging fruit several
items that were easy to work on on while
they were not major systemic issues they
were hardly
Band-Aids the special committee honored
their knowledge of working in the field
every day while they honored our
position as people approaching things
with outside pairs of eyes good work was
done but we knew there was much more to
do with a level of mutual trust having
been established My Hope was that the
speaker would reauthor authorized the
special committee for two more years so
we could focus on tougher issues several
of us saw three issues among others
number one was the level of ability of
counseling speaking only for myself
having spent 50 years giving pastoral
counseling I got the impression that the
quality of pre-trial counseling could be
improved
secondly we noted the wide variety from
court to court of what would and what
would not be admitted as evidence it is
a stated policy that the Rules of
Evidence in Family discre Family
Division are at the total discretion of
the judge because the superior court
operates on a different principle the
quick answer might be to move everything
from the Family Division there but we
are aware of other issues that would
then come into play therefore for
further work considerable further work
is needed and then three issues of
domestic violence and how they are
treated by the Family Division need
scrutiny we noted a lack of
communication between the Court's
hearing a case of such violence and with
a different court hearing matters of
divorce and custody with these matters
still outstanding some monks ago I asked
the special the speaker to give the
special committee two more years
since the conclusion of our special
committee's first two years last October
other state representatives have weighed
in on these matters some with bills of
their
own speaker response instead was to
suggest iform a subcommittee out of this
children and family law committee that
would work in some depth on the more
difficult issues
perceived children and family law submit
subcommitte on the Family Division of
Circuit Court of the State of New
Hampshire is hereby appointed in
consultation with the honorable Peter
Petrino ranking member I appoint a
subcommittee under my chairmanship
consisting of myself as its chair Vice
chairman Deborah D Simone representative
and family law attorney Jay marel former
chairman of this committee Kimberly rice
acting Deputy ranking member Alicia
Greg representative Heather Raymond and
representative Jody Nelson I will be
co-opting as regular Consultants a few
present and past house members who by
their training and experience will bring
expertise to our work we will work
thoroughly and not make haste however
should any aspect of our work conclude
by the end of October we may file bills
of sufficient depth and quality to to
make ma major changes worthy of our
judicial system and of the State of New
Hampshire so consider this
now
appointed thank you Mr chairman welcome
open the hearing on House Bill 493
requiring education on child abuse and
neglect for certain health care
providers as a condition for lure and
Greg thank you chairman and committee
for the record my name is Alicia Greg I
represent nasua in Ward 7 specifically
um I'm going to be doing this uh for
representative grman today in herstead
since she cannot be here with us um she
does send her regards to everyone this
bill is similar to one that we looked at
last year uh what this is doing is and
by the way we have a lot of different
bills I think partly because of the
special committee we worked on and
because of the intense work that we have
done in the last two years really kind
of tackling um our biggest problems all
in in different directions and this is
actually part of that so what this does
is this is talking about training um for
lure for Physicians and it's specific
and also for nurse practitioners and
Physicians assistants this is spe
specific to child abuse and neglect so
training um you know this is important
and I do have an amendment too that um
changes it from two hours of Education
to one hour of Education um I think we
can all agree that one hour is uh goes
pretty quickly so it's not a lot of time
but it's enough I think it's important
that we are educating people who see
this the most um not not only so that
they can understand what child abuse is
but also what child abuse is not um you
know we have heard a lot in hear not
only about uh child abuse cases getting
missed we also hear about um maybe
people being accused of child abuse that
it's not so I think that the only way we
can really prevent both of those and
help both of those is to really educate
I know other states even have
requirements believe it or not for um
beauticians for estheticians because
they're likely to have somebody in their
chair I can't imagine somebody more apt
to see abuse than any of these
professions so we do have um some people
willing to testify I also would like you
to look Dr Roy um said could not be here
she said that she was going to submit
some testimony but um there are other
people that can talk more to the
specifics but I can answer any questions
that you might have
maybe any questions for the
representative
representative marel yes thank you for
taking my question a little closer to
the mic please I'm sorry okay is that
better okay thanks closer okay u a
question okay with the hour that you've
mentioned now is this going to be one
hour to complete the requirement or is
this going to be an ongoing 1 hour each
reporting period so this is like many
other uh we see in medical professions
with new training continuing education
this is going to be for new lure or
continued lure so not every year but
certainly when you need to renew your
license okay but okay so if I'm hear
followup oh I'm sorry followup thank you
Mr chairman um so would this be one hour
one and done and that's it or every year
well not every year if you have
continued Li when you get your license
when you have that renewal then that's
what it looks like to me that it would
be an extra another hour chair has a
question uh
since I'm married to a physician and
since I'm part-time CEO of a medical
organization uh this does pop up
periodically called continuing education
would this be one of the hours that this
professional would be um required to do
in that reup year or would this be on
top of I'm going to defer that question
because I'm not sure and I want to make
sure you have accurate information thank
you thank you anything else
come on back all right thank
you chair recognizes uh Ben Bradley from
Association good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Ben Bradley I
represent all of the state's 26 acute
care hospitals and Specialty hospitals
in New Hampshire through the New
Hampshire Hospital
Association uh um hospitals and our
providers do take their obligation to
report any suspicion of child abuse or
neglect very seriously New Hampshire Law
requires any person who suspects that a
child under the age of 18 has been
report that suspicion immediately to DCF
under RSA
169-d colon 29 through
31 we agree that healthcare providers
are in a unique position to identify
children who have been abused or
neglected and support and promote the
programs that our members and others
offer to help educate providers on
reporting child abuse and
neglect however we do not believe the
education requirements proposed in HP
493 should be legislated healthc Care
Professionals already have a duty to
report as part of their professional
obligations to follow state and federal
regulations which includes many other
requirements ments such as their duty to
report elder abuse dog bites and
communicable
diseases singling out one type of
required training for mandatory
reporting seems to create
inconsistencies that inserts the
legislature and educational mandates
that do not exist anywhere else in
statute historically the legislature has
passed educational requirements for
opioid prescribing several years ago
however those statutory requirements
have since been repealed and left to the
Board of Medicine to
determine uh for these reasons the
hospital Association is resp
respectfully unable to support this bill
um I do want to thank you for the
opportunity to share our feedback I also
want to thank the proponents of this
bill because we have worked with them in
the past on raising awareness about the
educational opportunities that um they
support um particularly the office of
child advocate which does an incredible
job for the children in New Hampshire um
we have worked collaboratively with the
proponents of this bill and welcomed
them to our chief nursing officer
professional peer group to share their
thoughts on the importance of child
abuse and neglect reporting
training um and that information was
very well received by our members so I'm
happy to take you questions from the
committee Mr Bradley would it be your
many of the providers in the hospital
system are really ignorant of the signs
of abuse and neglect that they really
have never been much taught this and
that no one else in the facility would
catch it either unless this bill were to
pass uh I can't speak to that Mr
chairman that's not my sense um I think
our members do provide training to uh
the profession that are outlined in this
bill we've also as I mentioned welcomed
uh those proponents of this bill to our
peer groups through the hospital
Association to share uh the resources
that they're promoting um to try to get
our members to adopt that which I think
that information as I've mentioned was
well
received any questions from Mr
Bradley representative Raymond thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr Bradley for
taking my question so this is the second
time that this bill has come up in the
last couple of years and last time the
discussion was about um not training how
to call or when to call it's not
mandated report training it's training
about how to recognize the signs and
symptoms of abuse in the two years since
the last time this bill has come up has
the hospital Association adopted
voluntarily any additional signs of
child abuse and Mal treatment training
for their staff
well first I would just say um yes I
acknowledge that this bill has come up
before
um as far as our training um our members
do provide annual training to their to
their staff on child abuse and neglect
identifying and Reporting both of those
uh and as I've mentioned we've welcomed
the proponents of this bill to join with
the professional peer groups that we
host including Chief nursing officers at
our member facilities to share the
resources that they're promoting it's
not a question of whether training is
appropriate or whether they should be
aware of the importance of that training
or how to train or how to report we
believe that is very important which our
members do stand behind it's the
question of whether to put something in
statute that doesn't exist for anything
else for example would you promote
training and Reporting on on human
trafficking would you promote training
and Reporting on um elderly abuse other
things that are an expectation of the
providers that work within our system
and so we do believe that those are
important trainings it's just a question
of whether to mandate it through
legislative
statute representative
Pell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm am Vaguely
Familiar with the requirements of um
physician continuing medical education
training because I actually help keep
track of my own husband's training and I
know that they're required to complete
100 hours of continuing education every
two years and it would be my assumption
that any physician who was taking care
of um children or minors under the age
of 18 would probably be already alerted
for U or on the alert of child abuse and
neglect I mean if anybody who's taken
their child to a pediatrician knows that
their asked questions their child being
examined um they might even ask the
parents to leave the room so I I'm
personally find this to be a little bit
of overstep and an um a bit of an
undermining of physicians's Professional
Standards um would you be in agreement
with that um I would just e Echo was
that a would you believe it is kind of a
would you believe yes just say for the
record would you believe everything
said um I would just Echo what I've my
reflect in my testimony thank
you okay Mr Bradley um in the unlikely
event uh a professional at one of the
hospitals you represent should
miss this sign as it's unlikely with any
other thing that occasionally is missed
would there not be other team members
who would catch it I I don't think there
are any guarantees um whether you've
taken the training or not uh I think our
professionals make every effort to um
you know support their patients I think
they act in good faith um and I you know
am just here to try to represent their
voice as uh folks who come to work every
day and do their best in a very
challenging environment my followup to
that is is it unlikely that if somebody
is admitted to one of your the hospitals
you represent that person would be seen
by one Medical Professional only and no
other staff um respectfully Mr chairman
I don't know the answer to that I could
speak hypothetically uh from you know my
experience and uh going to a doctor um
there are typically at least a couple of
folks who will visit on a visit okay any
other question questions for Mr
Bradley seeing none thank you for your
testimony and I neglected to mention
this at the beginning couple things for
the new folks uh I prefer Mr chairman
not Mr chair uh Others May make other
decisions as people do with pronouns uh
also uh some committee
chairs uh really expect their seat
fillers to keep quiet until it's time to
vote I'm not one of those I'm glad
you're here I want want you to speak up
if even if you're just passing through
town raise your hand and prepared be
prepared to be called on I welcome you
to our group um next chair recognizes
Cassandra Sanchez from the New Hampshire
Office of the child
advocate welcome
back good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee and for the
record my name is Cassandra Sanchez I am
the child advocate for the State of New
Hampshire I am here this morning in
support of House Bill 493 um as well as
the amendment that was presented this
morning um so I'm going to start by
laying some groundwork as to how the
office the child advocate became
invested in this training um in the in
early
2020 we identified nine cases of
non-ambulatory infants that presented to
emergency departments with multiple
broken bones um in that time
frame thankfully none of those children
passed um but there were a large number
of them that had seen multiple doctors
before getting to the point of getting
the appropriate medical attention that
alerted that the cause of the injuries
were ultimately um result of abuse or
neglect we ultimately decided because
there were such a large number of those
in a short period of time and we're
talking about infants that can't speak
up for themselves that it was really
critical for us to take a look at this
issue and try to identify some gaps that
led us us there in August of 2023 the
OCA host did a system review mapping
which allows us to look at the larger
system issues and try to identify areas
of growth during that System review
mapping we had members of law
enforcement medical professionals um
specifically medical professionals that
had an expertise in ch AB child abuse
and neglect cases um including the the
cap doctor for the
state um and we also had present at that
uh mapping members of the department for
children youth and families and um
additional members of the community that
Pro they have um they Pro provide
services to families um during that
mapping one of the identified gaps was
trainings for doctors because we were
talking about some cases that included a
child presenting to the emergency
department first and an emergency doctor
not noting it as abuse or neglect and
having to be seen by a second level
doctor for that finding to occur we
recognized that there were some misses
at the emergency department level as
well as one of these was seen by their
pediatrician initially um and wasn't
brought back to the Ed until days later
when they continued with fussiness in
the home those were misses um those
children returned back to that family
environment until they were seen by
another professional and so in talking
with these professionals we said what
can we do to ensure these misses do not
continue again these were just
non-ambulatory infants this doesn't mean
that there other weren't other misses
that were happening with older children
maybe toddlers who were mobile and would
present to an ed with bruising and there
are areas of abnormal bruising there are
areas of normal bruising for toddlers
especially when they're mobile moving
around um so how many more misses were
out there we do not know and we don't
have a way to gather that information
but what we know is that we do not want
to continue to move in that direction we
want to ensure appropriate education to
keep that from happening in the future
so we met with and and and joined in the
efforts with the bill last session which
did not move forward um then over last
summer so summer 2024 we created a
presentation myself along with with the
medical doctors about what we observed
about the cases that the OCA observed
about additional cases that they have
observed including pictures of injuries
that were presented to emergency
departments or other doctors before they
made their way to a professional in
child abuse and it shows the extensive
amount of visits that occurred for some
children some of which are now left with
lifelong injuries and lifelong
disabilities because of what occurred to
them what occurred for them early in
their lives and because medical
treatment was not sought right away and
they were not placed in a safer
environment and continue
to get additional abuse within the home
that they resided so we worked together
to present that um those were presented
to multiple boards and professional
associations all of which I will say I
don't believe there was one person in
any of those rooms without their jaw
wide open when they received this
presentation and learned what some of
the children in our state had
experienced and many felt very strongly
that this was an appropriate ask it is
not addition to the hours that they
already have it is taking one of the
hours that they are required for
training to be allotted for the child
abuse and neglect training it was the
intention of this training is to ensure
that they are seeking out the signs and
the symptoms of abuse and are referring
to the appropriate entities to further
investigate such as the cap team such as
our child advocacy centers for
interviews if it is older children
ensuring that the appropriate
professionals are involved to provide
that more in-depth
review um the course was completed it is
an online course um it was it's
initially a two-hour course it was
presented it's been out there and
available for 5 months now in that five
Monon period 59 professionals from the
target population so that's um
Physicians U Physicians assistants aprns
59 um have taken it on their own that is
not representation of the professionals
across the state um so allowing it on a
voluntary basis is not bringing in the
amount of completion that we would hope
for at this point um RN have voluntarily
signed up for the course and there are
87 RNs that have completed the course um
up to this point so we actually have
more nurses that have completed it than
the medical professionals that we are
seeking to have complete this course um
so at this point from my perspective and
the work that we've done in the office
as well as as what I've learned from the
medical professionals some of which
we'll speak today is that this Gap
remains and this is a real critical gap
for us to close it is not a large ask
they are already conducting this
training to make sure that one hour is
allotted to abuse or neglect can protect
far more children than the amount of
hours that it's going to take away from
our physicians I am open to any
questions I heard you say that this is
not additional time but it is part of
their hours I do not see that reflected
in either the bill or the amendment so
if we were to pass the bill or the bill
is
amended uh your statement is
aspirational but it's not a requirement
it could be added on it just doesn't
say thank you for that comment I um had
some in-depth conversations with the
folks that developed it and I know that
was their intention behind it so that
I'm speaking on that was their intent of
bringing this bill forward was to have
it be one of the already allotted hours
for trading uh this bill is scheduled to
be exact and I could execute right after
this hearing I must exec it later this
afternoon I am going to defer until
later this afternoon to see if an
amendment could be brought forth that
would put into law if the bill passes
what you mentioned because uh I think
that would be helpful for some of us who
watch their spouses have to do a 100
hours every other year um any other
questions for uh uh Miss Sanchez yes
representative love thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh you mentioned the the
voluntary course was a two-hour course
do you think we might be skimping a
little bit by knocking it down to one
hour with the um with the amendment I'd
rather I'd rather have 15 minutes left
over people twiddling their thumbs and
than missing anything I will defer to
the doctors to answer that question for
you but my understanding and the way it
was explained to me is that um in
parsing it down the core critical
information was still included and they
felt that it was still substantial
enough but I will let them further
answer that thank you thank
you representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I do know uh
that and many of us know that you had
come from Massachusetts Massachusetts
does have this requirement in
statute um have you seen had you while
you were in Massachusetts doing your job
there uh seen any difficulty andic
professionals uh fulfilling this
requirement I did not see any difficult
difficulty with medical professionals
fulfilling that requirement um and I I
saw some wonderful relationships with um
local hospitals and pediatricians with
the child welfare agency and ensuring
that they had really open communication
and an understanding of um each each
other's roles and signs to look out for
follow up to her question were were
these uh was this continuing education
unit mandated by by law or was it done
by the professional agencies it is
mandated by law by law thank you any
other questions representative Pell yes
thank you Mr chairman and I will try to
ask a real question this time um my
question Massachusetts does have a lot
of exceptional requirements for
Physicians so much so that the license
is almost burdensome to maintain um my
question is regarding the actual section
of law do you think this would be better
under 3296 G where they see it
continuing Med medical education is
required for Physicians rather than in
um
169c I could not tell you which I
believe would be the better fit I just
think it's critical that we do have it
in our state laws
here representative love thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question again do you know if DC DCF
investigators are required to take a
course like this DCF investigators have
extensive amount of training that they
have to take um they have training when
they're on boarding as well as extensive
ongoing training um some of that is
offered to them by medical professionals
they um contract with the cap program
and um the doctors there and so they
have regular information sharing between
them um they have offered trainings um
extensive not in this sense because this
is more focused to medical professionals
but um in more coming from a a
psychology um Social Work standpoint
ensuring that they do know signs and
symptoms to look out for that they do
know um when certain disclosures are
made by children that they have to reach
out to certain entities they also um
work very closely with our child
advocacy centers the cac's here um in
New Hampshire and they also offer um
specialized training to dcyf staff so
they have a lot um and and much more
hours than um what we're asking here for
seeing no further questions thank you so
much for your testimony the chair
recognizes Dr Michael Matos from
wolfboro
Pediatrics and he has written testimony
uh apparently not enough for the
here all right thank you Mr chairman and
committee members I am Mike Matos I am a
general pediatrician wolf bro
Pediatrics and I'm here today in support
of the bill and I have three points that
I wanted to bring forward to the
committee first of all I think that
Physicians of all Specialties who treat
pediatric patients need this kind of
child abuse
training as part of my job at my
hospital I do receive a lot of the
emergency room notes for patients who
are seen as PE as uh as children even
for those patients who I don't
personally see in my practice
and one such note came through recently
which is representative of my concern so
a 7-year-old boy presented to the
Emergency Department emergency
department with his father for complaint
of
headache and the reason he had a
headache was because that day his
stepfather had hit him several times in
the head in
Anger the emergency department physician
appropriately noted all the physical
findings noted that the child had a neur
normal neurological exam but at the end
of the note it just said this patient
does not have a
concussion there was no discussion about
whether or not that patient needed to be
safely placed with his father until the
safety in the presence of The Stepfather
could be verified and there was no
mention of DCF being contacted and to
answer your earlier question about other
team members no one from the team that
DCF so that brings me to my second point
which is nobody goes to work and says I
want to do a bad
job there's a saying that learned
medicine that says you don't rise to the
training that lack of training prevents
a lot of Physicians from wanting to be
involved with one of these cases they
hand it off as soon as they possibly can
because they don't want to make an
error they don't want to do something
that harms the child and they don't want
to do something that might perhaps um
interfere with prosecution of a
perpetrator
so needing that training brings me to my
third point which is the proposed
coursework burden which is intended to
be part of that 100 hours by the way
it's not excessive so about 10 years ago
New Hampshire required that all
Physicians do the three hours of
training every two years learning about
pain medication and opioid addiction
treatment that year I signed up very
quickly because I wanted to satisfy that
need in my community and I treated two
patients who were in their 20s uh who
did have opioid
addiction they age out of my practice
since then I haven't had a c single
patient who has needed treatment for
opio addiction but I continue to do my
hours of training every two years
because that was what was required for
lure in order for me to do a good
job I'll just finish by saying that
Physicians do a lot of training and
travel to conferences to do one hour of
training for things that they might see
once in their career or for things that
are one in a million child abuse is very
common and it's something that whether
they know it or not Physicians are
running into on a regular basis if they
treat
children with one hour of training I
expect
that Physicians will be shown how to
recognize child abuse how to triage it
to the appropriate uh agencies that will
help them
and that's what we really need in place
and that's why I support the bill I'll
take any other questions any questions
for Dr Matos representative
love thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question in your professional
enough um again I think child abuse is
very common it's fairly complex that's
why there are child abuse
experts um but I think
again giving Physicians the tools saying
this is what child abuse looks like and
this is what you should do when you run
into a case like this that's again
giving them the tools to do these things
will make
them more assured when they meet a
patient who might have some child abuse
rather than trying to bury it under the
rug and maybe dish it off to someone
else representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question it's kind of
a two part
question do you believe that
um most Physicians and medical staff are
aware that they are mandated reporters
and the fact that they don't always
rushed um
so I I've taken the course part part of
the course explains just what you asked
that everyone in New Hampshire is a
mandated
reporter um we actually after this case
came through my uh through my hospital
we reminded everyone that this we are
all uh mandated
reporters
um I I part of the um the training deals
with the actual reporting and I
think like I said that's part of the
toolbox that people need in order to
cases followup or second question second
part of the question follow up to the
first
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again do you believe that this
training will uh remind more often that
these mandated reporters shall report
suspected abuse and neglect rather than
feel Rush
patient well I I don't think the rushing
is part of it like I said earlier I
think it's the discomfort with wanting
to do the wrong thing not complete the
note in such a way that it's going to
support the child that's what I see more
often than I I was too busy to report it
um and the interesting thing is The
Physician who sees the patient doesn't
have to be the one to do the report that
can go to another member of the team so
it isn't necessarily a burden and again
the course uh as I saw it went through
how to do a report and I think that's
very helpful for Physicians to
know thank you second
question you're all
said you're welcome representative
coren thank you Mr chair and thank you
for answering my question um from
listening to the story about the
seven-year-old who came in it sounds
like that physician didn't necessarily
need an education on the signs and
symptoms but on his responsibility as a
physician
um if I may follow up to that
um is there any accountability to
Physicians who just don't want to report
it because they don't want to get
involved
because they're putting a child at risk
uh yes that that is um part of a law
that exists I believe um and part of the
reporting law says that you are not um
responsible um for mistakenly making a
report and so yes that that was part of
the training to explain that sort of
subtlety but I agree you want com you
want Physicians to feel comfortable
doing the reports
and as you said it was clear from the
note that the physician recognized what
the situation was but just didn't take
that next step didn't realize that you
really do have to contact DF in those
cases it seems
obvious um but a lot of these things do
in
retrospect representative grund thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question uh is the Assumption of
training being done the same as the
requirement in knowing is getting done
and the reason I'm asking is Can it can
you believe that pediatric doctors
nurses Pas LPN are probably receiving
training considering they work with
children but emergency room doctors
urgent care doctors maybe just general
not yeah exactly so um you do have that
100 hours where you can choose what you
want to
study um I think that as I said we study
a lot of things as Physicians that we
may not see in our in our practice at
all and there there's one in a million
things and yet we know exactly how to do
that work up and
and treat that patient and yet child
abuse is so much more common and um so I
think it's very reasonable to say this
should be part of your biannual training
um to understand the subject and it's
not an
in-depth understanding you don't have to
deal with those subtle cases where is it
is it abuse or is it not it's that's you
at least have to know how to get the
material seeing no further questions
thank you doctor thank you very much
chair recognizes Dr gwendaline
Gladstone the Hampshire chapter of the
American Academy of pediatric Pak those
people little people and would you
believe I have a granddaughter named
gwendolin
please Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for letting me speak
today my name is gwendelyn Gladstone I
am a retired child abuse
pediatrician um and I'm here to help
explain to you why we need to have this
bill what's different about educating
providers about child abuse and neglect
is that many of us haven't had very
comprehensive training and therefore
when kids come in with minor signs or
symptoms that they're being mistreated
that can be missed and the child
returned to an environment where they're
further injured that of course is a
travesty it's also not acceptable if a
child is mistakenly thought to have been
abused but in fact has some other
medical condition and an investigation
is done of the family and maybe even and
the child is placed outside of the
family as part of an evaluation we don't
want that to happen either um you might
be surprised to hear that when children
are referred to a child abuse specialist
because of concerns of abuse that abuse
is actually diagnosed less than half the
time so a lot of the reason to improve
the education for our providers is to be
sure we're calling it right calling the
abuse when it's there and not
overcalling it when it's not there in
addition Dr Matos has talked about the
impact of providers wanting to do the
right thing so what's different here
about child abuse from any other medical
topic that we don't have laws requiring
education the difference is the number
of cases that we see in the field of
children who are missed and who are not
reported um and because of the long-term
effects on even one child the cost of
one brain damaged child from Abus of
head trauma is in the order of millions
of dollars so we can't we just can't
have that um many states have have
adopted requirements for this as a
condition for lure and almost always
it's because there was some incredibly
terrible public catastrophe um so for
example in New York they made this a
they made a requirement for education on
these topics when a six-year-old was
severely neglected raped and murdered um
Pennsylvania passed its law which is
three hours for lure and two hours to
renew after the sanduski affair um Maine
has a requirement because of a child who
died who presented multiple times with
signs of abuse and it was not there was
no intervention done so because the case
that we're seeing that's why we need to
do this um you mention
providers need to have need to know they
have to report they do know they have to
report but they don't and the reasons
are they're not sure they don't know how
to answer the question of is this abuse
or not they don't know where to go for
help they don't know how to do an
evaluation to look for other signs
hidden signs um they don't want to get
involved because they don't know how to
talk to a family about their concerns
about abuse and neglect these are all
topics that are covered in the toour
course that we have available and which
as Miss Sanchez has told you people are
not taking there are thousands of
providers that get emails every month
reminding them of this course and 59
have signed up so that those are the
reasons why we need to have this
mandated thank you for listening I'm
happy to take
questions any questions for the doctor
representative love thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
thank you for taking my question um the
uh child abuse is a pretty complex thing
as as you've described there do you
think one hour is enough I don't but do
you think and you mentioned two hours
yes we currently have a course that's
two hours long and meets the
requirements of a former proposed bill
which did not pass um it covers the
topics of recognition reporting and
working with the child protection system
we felt that that course was more
comprehensive than would be necessary
for for example an orthopedist who might
see children
occasionally my husband's a retired
cardiologist he saw adults but every
once in a while a 17-year-old would come
through his office he would have to take
this kind of training um and the
material that's in the 2-hour course is
more comprehensive than people in those
kinds of roles really need to
I we believe it can be safely lowered to
1 hour so the requirement may be 1 hour
but we'll still keep the two-hour course
available so people in particularly in
Primary Care Hospital medicine emergency
medicine if they want to take the
two-hour course there it is it's free
they get their free continuing education
credits um but one hour is sufficient
for many people who only see children
occasionally thank
you any further questions for the doctor
representative Rong thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned some of the
states that have this requirement do you
know how many total in the United States
have it how many states yes um well I'm
aware of Iowa New York Pennsylvania
Maine
Delaware
um off the top of my head those are the
ones I can think
of seeing no further question questions
thank you doctor for your testimony you
say you have written copies a few I have
a I have copy of uh my testimony also
from Dr oral who's the former head of
the child abuse program and from another
provider in the child abuse program
would you be so kind is to give them to
my committee researcher who at your
convenience make enough copies for
everybody else including we don't have
enough of Dr mat's testimony so if
somebody would hand her a copy of his so
while she's up at the fourth floor at
some point uh that one is coming up his
is okay good thank
you well Dr Matos was shy about seven or
eight and Dr
Gladstone about
15 okay welcome oh chair recognizes
Betty
gay The Honorable
Betty gay served your time thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
hearing this really sensitive issue um I
can just add to the professionals My
Views as a person watching people who
may be reluctant to uh reluctant to
report something that they're not sure
about uh the question the very serious
question that came up last year was is
this going to add to the two hours or
one hour to the training that a medical
personnel have to come well anybody who
has to acrew hours is going to make sure
that whatever course they sign up is
approved by that agency that's counting
the hours so we already know that there
are professional courses right now
available and they are approved uh for
this purpose so we don't have to worry
that we're adding extra burden
to to the professionals to take the
class um refreshing information
knowledge is never a bad idea if you've
got to take a 100 hours and 50 are
really very very rated very
important it never hurts to be refreshed
on things that you studied before but
there's always the chance that there's
new information that has been identified
so it's never a going to hurt to be
refreshed uh and the issue that the man
who represents hospitals was saying some
of us were nodding our heads as he was
saying well why mandate this when we
have so many other reportable uh issues
well sure go ahead and mandate it if
it's if it's happening a lot and people
are getting hurt that's okay but that's
not an argument against something that
we know exists sadly exists a lot
um in the last two days I had the most
unsettling experience because I usually
don't have to think about child abuse
but in two days yesterday I got called
by a mother whose children she's watched
being hurt she's been hurt uh and is
struggling uh who really appreciates
Miss Sanchez's organization who has been
helping ful but her children are
severely severely autistic and and
reacting from being hurt and one of the
problems they have are broken bones from
being thrown against a wall or even
against a bed that was so hard it broke
the
bed then the day before I'm talking with
friends celebrating a
birthday and the subject of her husband
as an adult going undergoing treatment
for cancer he was x-rayed and the doctor
looking at those x-rays said did you
play
football and he said no he says any
contact
Sports no he has so many broken
bones in his
body and he forgot why he had them this
is a common thing for a child who AB
been abused they suppressed the memories
so they went home and called his sister
who's a few years older and said oh yes
our father threw you against the wall
all the
time child abuse exists it's ugly it's
horrible it's left me shaking I'm
gradually getting over the impact of
just hearing about this but it happens
all the time and we need to take the
steps to make sure it gets recognized
and this bill of course is going to
remind them how to report so please pass
this we're not adding to the
burden but we're going to reveal and
help children who are being abused thank
you former representative gay does
anyone have any questions for her uh
thank Youk the chair would like to call
you cited numbers of people who have
taken your course the uh course that I
assume the New Hampshire chapter is
generated yes are there other courses
that deal with the same material that
other physicians may have taken on this
subject um the I don't believe so and
the reason is that particularly
mentioned in this course
um is how the child protection system in
New Hampshire works so there are plenty
of national courses on child abuse and
neglect but they're not State specific
most Physicians get their training
outside of New Hampshire and then come
to our state to practice and as a result
they're not familiar with our laws and
part of the reason to have a course like
this is to explain how New Hampshire
fines physical abuse emotional abuse
sexual abuse so and so forth um and
that's why I don't believe there are
other courses at the present time there
there certainly could be that's why the
law the bill says that if there is
another course like that as long as it
covers these topics as determined by the
uh New Hampshire chapter of the American
Academy of Pediatrics it would fulfill
the requirements my followup is
certainly if a requirement in your mind
is that they're educated in the laws of
New Hampshire I would doubt that taking
a course that comes from elsewhere you
would ever recognize anyone else other
than your own
course I'm
sorry I'll rephrase my question if other
places have courses on the recognition
of child abuse and
neglect but they do not mention specific
New Hampshire things when the bill says
that credited for a course that is
recognized by the New Hampshire chapter
of the Academy of Pediatrics you
wouldn't recognize those other courses
because in your opinion they don't deal
with New Hampshire issues that's correct
it's important that providers know
specifically how to work with a system
in New
Hampshire so no one else would be
recognize other than your own course
they would if they included that if they
included in Hampshire things correct
okay thank you so much chair recognizes
fry and you know I thought you were
representing OPEC but then I realized
you wrote in lowercase letters so you're
really oplc right that is correct Mr
chair and have you replaced uh attorney
USA house I have correct okay thank you
I'll change my phone sure okay well
actually my I I took his landline so if
you have his landline I'll have the same
number that he had previously I'll
change just the name okay thank you
counselor
proceed well thank you all for having me
I appreciate it um we don't take any
position on this bill I just reviewed
the language in the statute and we had
some concerns about how we would
operationalize it if it did go through
so I wanted to um raise those concerns
with you um so you're aware of them so
the bill as currently written seeks to
require those who are licensed as a
physician physicians assistant or nurse
practitioner and treats patients under
age uh 18 to take certain education
requirements um as the statute kind of
says we license individuals to practice
as a physician a physician assistant a
nurse practitioner we don't license
people to practice as a pediatrician or
to work with people who are under the
age of
18 um so because of
that we don't collect data on specialty
areas for doctors or nurse practitioners
or physicians assistant and your license
when you get it right is a license to
practice as a physician or physician
assistant or as a nurse practitioner so
even during your two-year term right
we've heard a couple people talk about
the two-year renewal cycle that you have
you could technically practice in
multiple areas with your license um
because there's no restriction on that
I'm not so so the issue there then is
that we have concerns about how we'd be
able to operationalize the bill as
currently written because we're not
tracking who is a pediatrician and who
works with children under
18 I think this is a very important
point that we all need to hear back up
about a sentence and a half please sure
yep so because because we license
Physicians and we license Physicians
assistants and we license nurse
practitioners and they have everybody
has a specialty right we all know that
in medical practice but that's not what
we're licensing we don't really have
that data so for us to operationalize
the bill as currently written where it's
so specific to um treating patients
under the age of 18 to take certain
requirements we don't really have the
ability to do that we don't it would be
an honor System essentially right
someone would say would take the
course because they think it's the right
thing to do and I don't know whether if
someone's in a you know if you're in a a
primary care physician and you take on a
a patient that's under 18 and maybe you
didn't expect to do that we have no way
to track that because you have a
physician's license you don't have a
license to treat someone under the age
of
18 any question specifically on that
point representative Raymond by a nose
thank you Mr chairman um thank you um
attorney for sry for for taking my
question um
so so it sounds like that would mean
that this requirement to take the
training um would apply to everybody on
the list regardless of what specially
what specialty area they practice in so
someone working at a nursing home as a
you know um physician assistant would
also have to take this
training so so was currently written
that's that's not the way I'm reading it
but but based on your ability to track
it right you wouldn't be able to correct
right opt people out you would ask
everyone to just do it correct we
wouldn't have that data and even if we
had that data right you have you have a
license to practice as a physician or a
nurse practitioner or a physician's
assistant so maybe today you're working
as a pediatric I don't know right and
then you decide you want to change your
specialty we don't have any way to track
that during a two-year period because
they've been giving a license to
practice as a physician
thank you follow up uh no followup I'm
good ready to go you had a question go
oh I'm
sorry finishing second today is
representative Nelson sorry about that
um so um thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um would you have a suggestion on how we
could rewrite this bill as an amendment
to um solve that problem so
I our office we try to be very concerned
with not inserting ourselves in
legislating I'm happy to tell you like
what the concern is so the concern is
that um it's the requirement is for
folks that are under um treating
patients that are under the age of 18
and so we don't have a license type that
really fits that right it's you have a
generic Physician's license you have a
generic
um It's kind an all or nothing right if
that I don't know if that helps answer
your question a little
bit any further questions representative
rung thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so currently New
Hampshire has a minimum amount of hours
that are required for ler renewal how
many of those hours are currently
mandated to have training in a specific
area um well it depends on what board
you're looking at so for inance medicine
it's you've got I'm just pulling up
their continuing education rule right
now but they have different categories
they have category one category two um
and then they have to be I'm looking at
category one it says the courses shall
be courses or activities which satisfy
the current requirements of the American
Medical association's physician
recognition award program so I mean it's
it's fairly broad um but it really
depends on what you're looking at for
I'm not even looking at physician
assistants or um nurse practitioners so
it's kind
of um I mean there were the opioid
credits that folks have talked about
right that's a
mandatory um I forget how many hours it
is but um that's a mandatory credit
that's kind of like Universal for each
one of those uh license types I don't
know if it's
helpful
y any further
questions thank you counselor all right
well thank you for your time today I
appreciate it your name is much easier
to pronounce than UT and I've been
working on that just tell him if you see
Doug and unlike attorney osterhout I am
a Red Soxs fan not a Yankees
followup all right he can come back
and chair recognizes Kathy Stratton from
the New Hampshire Medical
[Music]
Society and what is your position with
that m
the
CEO are you a lawyer a
physician you're a
Miz
okay thank
you dear Mr chairman members of the
House children and family law committee
my name is Kathy Stratton I'm speaking
on behalf of the new New Hampshire
Medical Society and representing the
medical society's 20 physician members
in opposition to House Bill 493 which
would require education on child abuse
and neglect for certain Health Care
Providers as a condition of
licensure I want to acknowledge the
physicians Dr Gladstone and Dr Aral who
have come forward to elevate the
importance of identifying and Reporting
child abuse on this our
vision and priorities are in alignment
this is an unusual position where the
medical society and a medical specialty
are not aligned the medical society and
our members are already working outside
of the legislative process to increase
awareness for child abuse detecting and
Reporting the New Hampshire Medical
society's board councel and legislative
committee believe that this is an issue
better addressed by the medical board
medical society and Physicians rather
than
legislatively if passed this bill
requires new and renewing Physicians and
other practi practioners who treat
patients under 18 two or one however
that that lands um on child abuse and
neglect on an ongoing basis Physicians
are already required to complete a 100
hours of continuing medical education
every two years we believe this could
and should include a broad spectrum of
training and education that relates to
improved clinical and practice knowledge
and skill designating this issue as a
requirement for all Physicians creates a
man mandate that we that may be relevant
for some but may not for all while
pediatricians and emergency physicians
may see these cases more often other
Specialists or clinicians noted in the
bill May rarely if ever be in a position
to report child abuse requiring this
broadly as a bill as this bill does
regardless of relevance to practice may
be inefficient and
unnecessary while child abuse education
is undoubtedly important
legislating a strict condition of lure
adds another layer of complexity cost
and administrative burden many
Physicians already receive education on
child abuse through their medical
training workplace protocols or existing
CME
requirements mandating an additional
course may lead to redundancy rather
than meaningful improvements in patient
care or reporting practices we believe a
more flexible non- leg lative approach
would be more effective without being
unnecessarily burdensome for this reason
we cannot support House Bill 493 as
written and amended thank you for your
time and consideration of my testimony
it would be your testimony Contra to the
testimony of a few others that as you
read the bill and the amendment it does
in fact not say anything about whether
these one or two hours would be included
in the 100 hours or not it would be your
inference it would be an add-on as it
was somebody else's inference it was
included in in both cases
inferences and it's it's definitely
rice thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you had mentioned
that they get training in their uh
during like their medical training um
when they're training for the position
what if they're doing that in New York
and we're in New Hampshire how do we
assure that they are getting training on
New Hampshire's child abuse
statute thank you for the question um
our position is that it is not that the
the training is not relevant or
shouldn't be happening our position is
that it shouldn't be
legislated um we're working with um the
physicians in the state to bring that
information however um that's relevant
to the state um however it when it's
mandated on an ongoing basis that's our
concern
followup thank you again for taking um
another question so
um how do you respond then to the
numbers that we were given of only 59
doctors actually taking the course
voluntarily and the fact that 87 nurses
have I I'm certain we have far more than
59 doctors and 87 nurses in the
state thank you for the question um I
think my response would be that um this
has been newly initiated um and we need
to raise awareness for it we need to
encourage our physicians to be um to
take the training it's available um
we've we've published articles about
this in our physician magazine and
distributed it um just in the last three
weeks to um all Physicians across the
state were posting this information on
our website um I think that there are
non- legislated opportunities here for
making this um Education and Training
available would you believe I know
enough about politics that sometimes the
threat isn't what it seems to
be can you repeat
that I think you want me to explain it
um that sometimes s when the legislature
or a different branch of government
makes what seems to be onf face value a
threat we are really just trying to
encourage others to say hey wait a
minute there's a lot of us out here who
want this what are you going to do about
it that uh often in response people step
up um my question is to what degree is
the New Hampshire Medical Society aware
of what to at least me from my phone and
email is a ground swell of people people
saying you got to do something about
this more than is being done now are you
aware of that as a board absolutely we
are um and and like I said we're working
we're working with our pediatrician
Partners um to make this available and
to raise awareness um you
know I I think I think that um this
piece of legislation has brought forward
that issue and and and whether it needs
to be legislated or not um I think it's
elevated it in a in a very important way
um and that's why I started my testimony
with with an acknowledgement for those
that came forward um I'm going to start
my followup with a sentence that leads
into a question and the sentence is I
have asked some Physicians and nurses
not necessarily on my own
staff describe what you look for in
abuse and neglect and was very pleased
if the articulation they gave
I asked them had they taken the
course that was referenced here this
morning and they said no we just know
this yeah so my question is have you had
similar conversations with Physicians
nurse practitioners Physicians
assistants and the like and received
similar uh responses that they do
know we actually no we haven't um you
know I
think our position has always been to
advocate for those vulnerable people and
um you know we we haven't we haven't
looked for the the negative you know in
this um only that we want to support it
we just don't want to see it legislated
okay all righty uh so on the other hand
representative coal coron thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here
um I understand that you're saying that
you don't think it should be legislated
however um what does your Society say
about a physician who hears that a
seven-year-old was hit in the head and
has to go to the emergency room and then
that physician just forgets about it
um how is how does your Society plan on
taking a stand against that so no other
child has to do
that thank you for the question um it's
devastating I think you know the every
physician takes an oath to do no harm
and anytime a situation like that AR is
I think it's devastating um you know the
society itself you know again is here to
promote the education and the um
engagement with um and the resources
that may be
available um you know that seems to be
more of a an issue for the licensing
society representative rice thank you
again Mr chairman thank you you for
taking another question so this this
bill language came out I believe last
year this committee heard this bill but
yet you stated that only three weeks ago
you sent out in a magazine the import or
whatever you send out the importance of
taking this continuing education so how
are we to believe that that's going to
happen when this legislation's been
heard before and it took how long just
to get something sent
out thank you for the question
representative rice
um I've been the CEO of the medical
society for five months uh so this is a
relatively new position for me and um
I'm not sure what position was taken by
my predecessor or you know in the past
um you know the the training and the um
the opportunities offer offered by Dr
Gladstone and Dr or
came to our attention and we immediately
put it in our magazine um and we we
immediately promoted it in our Weekly
Newsletter um so so when it came to my
attention I took immediate
action
followup do you happen to have the
numbers of the people who have signed up
since you sent out your
newsletter we don't have access to that
information I'm sorry I can I can look
at I can I can actually
provide um some feedback on on who's
clicked on the links if that would be
helpful for the
committee you may not be the one to ask
this question to but since uh Ben
Bradley is left um don't hospitals
provide this training to new
hires that would be a question for the
hospitals like I said you you may not be
the one am not aware I was of that
opinion okay but that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean a negative it's not it's
just it's my own limited awareness of it
okay question over here from
representative George thank you Mr
chairman and I thank you to have my
question um I just because I'm just
reading this um testimony uh the way she
explained here almost 40 years I practic
in the seal first as a a primary care
provider and then a special she support
really because if she she know she think
not she think but she supported that
that bill because for how many kids go
back home um not reported and they they
have a problem because for that then
what how you can oppose that because
just canot prove me for that I think I
need to clarify that we are
absolutely not saying that we how do I
say we absolutely absolutely support
efforts to increase
the detection and reporting of child
abuse it's the mandating it
to follow up
please follow
up thank you Mr chairman and um for me
you just can for me because if I hear
everybody what they say and to read all
those testimony I think so this is very
important um for the state for the State
of New Hampshire and I think so is
better for us
to to get a a right decision that why I
can
say if you don't think
so got to hit the button again I'm sorry
I hit you instead of me here thank you
you representative love thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question now uh you You' stated your
your opposition is to the Mandate and uh
you know child abuse is a thing that's
been going on since the be beginning of
time and uh you know it's uh others have
has testified that uh the uh the courses
have been offered and they're available
yet it doesn't seem like anybody's uh
stepping up and taking them uh this is
the reason for a mandate uh if uh can
you explain further explain how you know
that uh you know just a voluntary thing
might work where it hasn't thank you
representative love um I think I think
the feedback that you got was that this
was the participation in this particular
course and again I think it's my from my
understanding it's relatively new so um
I think to say broadly that Physicians
and other clinicians are not engaging in
child abuse training
education um may be unwarranted from
that particular fact um so I I you our
physician members are very very
conscientious and um they want to do
their best and um they take an oath to
First Do no harm and if this
if this course is available and um which
it is and I I I mean I strongly believe
participation thank you representative
grund thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so it's same
question I asked earlier to another
person um but is the Assumption of
training being done the same as a
requirement and knowing it is getting
done thank you representative for the
question
um I'm trying to think of how to answer
that because the data of whether it's
being done or not is probably available
um Physicians are going online they
every two years it's part of their
requirements they um are required to
report to CE broker what courses they
took and and um I would assume that the
data is out there for you know present
and past to look at which courses are
being taken um and and what the what the
impact of that might be um you know I
think this is this is front and foremost
on people's minds right now so my you
know and that's why we put it in the
physician magazine is just that it's
really important for our physicians to
update their training to refine and
refresh their skills um and again it's
it's not about the it's not about the
training it's the Mandate um you know
and and I think that there there are
other opportunities to look at this um
it could be it could be taken to the
medical board um where it could be
discussed there that would be another
Avenue for which um that and other
licensing boards um rather than having
it um enacted in state
law since I have received several phone
calls from people indicating other
mandated courses that the legislature
should
require uh would you join me in being
concerned that a bill like this that on
the sole issue of mandate nothing else
right would open or widen a Floodgate of
many bills essentially now uh telling
how
CE medical continuing education units
should be conducted that's that that's
right that's a strong concern of the
medical society okay thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you and I
have no more pink cards um so I am going
to close the hearing on
493 and um I I I have
to have an exec session on this sometime
today I could open it and then postpone
it two weeks I could do that or um with
some of the uh possible suggestions on
the amendment
662 such as specifically saying this is
not additional but part of and looking
at the question that was raised should
this be under 32916 on six not 169
possibly an amendment could be crafted
over the lunch hour uh I hate to deprive
you of lunch but uh would you uh and and
my clerk as the co- mentioned Amendment
people be amendable to my giving you a
little bit more time we def thank you Mr
chairman we definitely need more time I
do think we'll be able to get an
amendment to you by this afternoon and
if it's this afternoon great and if not
we got two weeks yep that sounds good
thank you you're welcome see that's the
advantage of being the acting full
ranking
honorary minority party I'm looking for
the the noun in here um goddess works
it all right now for those of you who
are watching or sitting there watching
and
listening um I'm inclined not to start
the exact session on House Bill
10 um in about 20 or minutes or so
simply because we're going to have to
stop for lunch so if
um if the next Bills
hearing goes short and we have about 10
or 15 minutes I will open an exact
session on on ones that are relatively
easy in other words hb10 will not be
exact until this afternoon probably
about 1:00 so that's for those of you
who want to plan your
day I now open the hearing on House Bill
543 establishing a committee to study
how the Family Division customarily
treats accusations of domestic violence
and to study current Family Division
practices relative to the right to
testify and right to submit evidence and
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
who will eventually give us a pink card
doesn't have to be right
now wow you did that in three seconds
Lichfield so uh Mr chairman I have
submitted this bill on behalf of a
former representative may she come up as
well in the interest of Saving Time okay
it's your on it are you liking I am the
prime sponsor representative Lichfield I
have put the can't hear you I the prime
too much noise go ahead I am the prime
sponsor representative Lichfield I have
put the bill in on behalf of the
honorable Betty gay in the interest of
time I was wondering if she could come
up right now sounds like a plan you was
so good in your Speedy getting the pink
card in how can I refuse thank you I
appreciate I'd like to say um I really
appreciate all that you do I sat here
listening through the last hearing and
um it was difficult just to listen so
just know you're appreciated wow and we
may all honor representative Malone who
has about to
change the paper that sits on the table
that lets everyone know or her designate
fine see we run a loose ship here
we were discussing in our committee
yesterday do do you get a plate for that
do you get a parking spot and a is it
leadership that's above my pay grade
representative she does she gets down
atore street oh she does it's called
stores garage oh sweet
yeah you know they're going to have that
new garage ready for us to vacate this
building you know that yeah that's how
we work here representative former
Bill thank you Mr chairman I thought I
was going to come in as Part B you are
part B she just did part A you if I do a
quick oh would you like to do part a i
three seconds chairman Mr chairman so
House Bill 543 this bill establishes a
study committee to examine the practices
of the Family Division of the court in
relation to domestic violence the
establishment of this study committee is
crucial to ensure we're meeting legisl
ative best practices aimed at improving
the Court's capacity to minimize risk
and harm to families during the
proceedings of the special Committee of
the family court extensive testimony was
presented on the issue of domestic
violence however due to the
comprehensive nature of the committee
scope there was inadequate time to
thoroughly examine this specific topic
furthermore while the governor has a
commission on domestic violence that
covers a broad scope including aspects
including law enforcement this study
committee would focus specifically
excuse me on any legislation needed
court thank you I would like to uh point
out that the subcommittee if if created
would be addressing immediately the
denial of constitutional rights of due
process of accepting testimony or
accepting evidence that's something I
think that can be addressed immediately
because the violation of constitutional
rights is exceedingly serious We As
Americans have these constitutional
rights but New Hampshire family court
allows a judge to decide whether or not
you get them that's not a right okay
that's a privilege and family court
needs to run on rights so my suggestion
is you either pass the bill this
afternoon that would immediately do that
or you immediately address it in this in
this uh um
proposal
um the governor's commission I attended
some of those there was no testimony
when I went from the people affected it
was just all the agencies so agencies
sat around and talked about what they do
but they weren't addressing the issues
as people who were not treated well and
uh so they didn't talk about the
problems that needed to be addressed so
I guess this is pretty simple what I'm
asking you to do either pass the
correction now this afternoon in House
Bill 5
652 or a re accept the fact that it's a
serious serious violation of our
constitutional rights and address it
immediately in a a study committee and
put in a bill don't talk about it for
two years more I would address the
representative and former representative
asking were you here when I
appointed a subcommittee to deal with
exactly this that was appointed this
morning yes I heard that so I'm going to
move itl when we get to exact not
because it's a bad Bill it's a great
bill it's been done if you would have
pass if we would have passed this bill
and then it crosses over to the Senate
and then the Senate deals with it and
then it gets to the governor and then it
gets assigned and then they call me
asking who should be on this
committee from the house point of view
it might that subcommittee or that
committee might start its work in
September or June but not until then it
won't happen today if we execute
positively has to go to the floor has to
go to the Senate has to go to the
governor but the subcommittee of this
committee that was appointed this
morning has two specific things to look
at and this is one of them so it has
been
appointed duplication would not undo the
subcommittee duplication would be highly
confusing I think our IQs are higher
than that I think some of the people who
are most interested in this will be very
welcome as guests at our subcommittee
yes but if you are sir if you are asked
to start another committee you already
have the people selected and you could
even add more people to it we really
need to involve more people so that it's
because lots of us are very concerned
about domestic abuse and uh what the the
problems facing family court but we
don't have a huge number of people
aware any questions any questions for
table thank you seeing none thank you
for your testimony and this concludes
the
hearing ranking member are we ready to
EXA this say I because we have just
appointed the
committee
okay okay as in my discretion I open the
exec session on this bill and the chair
moves
itl second was whom representative rice
wishes to and I will speak to my motion
simply by repeating what I just said
we've got the committee in place we are
very aware of this and we're ready to
roll this is a wonderful bill but is no
longer
this and when the one of the clerks two
clerks no waiting you should get another
clerk you know that not that you're not
good but uh you know it's always good to
have backup uh the chair will call the
role the motion is itl moved by The
Chair seconded by representative rice
the former chair and it is it L would
the clerk please call the role if you
are in favor of itl that's a yes
motion another words you have to vote
bill you may call the rooll either one
of any of you first oh
first chairman pearon yes representative
D
Simone yes representative rice yes
representative MC Mayan yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Patell Pell yes representative love the
clerk votes yes representative marel yes
representative Greg yes representative
Levesque yes representative rang yes
representative grund yes representative
Raymond yes representative George
yes and representative Malone
yes 16 to
zero I can't hear you uh I move
consent is that okay uh yeah consent
everybody good thank you and through the
543 and through the miracle of modern
technology I have the blurb
bu what was the vote what was the vote
to 16 to
nothing and like I say I just want to
say it again it's a great Bill and had
this not special subcommittee been
appointed I'd say go for it so we did it
in a different
way uh all right
um that concludes the exec session
on uh 5:43 and since it's past 11:00
which means this is legal I will now
open an exact session on um House Bill
430 an act reducing the retention period
for records of unfounded abuse and
neglect reports by the Department of
Health and Human Services and the chair
recognizes representative rice for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move itl
on House Bill 430 and the second
representative Greg and representative
rice would you speak to the motion
please yeah so
um are you ready for me yep okay um
so reports of abuse and neglect can be
deemed unfounded but maintaining those
records can show a pattern and this is
something we just put into Statute in
like 2017
and you know no one else has access to
your reports it's all confidential so
the the the concerns we heard about you
know employers finding out or things
like that just don't
happen um so for those reasons and for
protecting
children I'm moving
itl anyone else wish to speak to it
representative Greg and I would like to
reiterate for everyone that this is not
you know not something that people can
get a hold of um and and it also helps
out when we're looking at statistically
how things are looking in the state how
our courts are handling things um
looking at these reports if the courts
have to get into them is very very
important but once again it is not
something anyone can just go check like
a a sex offender registry or anything
else so um while I think this is good
intentioned for some people people it's
misplaced and would overall do more harm
than
good representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to add that um
from a supporting the child uh or
children standpoint um we also discussed
that there may be an unfounded report on
abuse of child a um but subsequent um
abuse May intensify to children B and C
and that might be recognized and and uh
those children were supported but
looking back at a
history um child
a might also need that type of support
uh that wouldn't necessarily have been
recognized in the first report that was
unfounded and Mr representative rice and
if I could just add that the pattern can
not only show a pattern of abuse or
neglect but it could also show a
a pattern of malicious
reporting so I think this benefits all
areas thank
guests that's not to say they're not
honorable but you know what I mean up
here seeing uh no further discussion the
motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 430 moved by
representative rice seconded by
representative Greg one of the clerks
please call the
role chairman Pearson yes representative
D Simone yes representative rice
representative McMahan yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Pat petno yes representative love yes
representative coren yes representative
marel yes representative Greg yes
representative lavesque yes
representative rang yes representative
grund yes representative Raymond yes
representative georgees yes
representative
Malone yes 16 chair calls on the acting
rank uh ranking member for a reminder of
the chair would you like this to go on
consent I would any objections
and if we could have a report from
representative rice uh sometimes wow
here
imagine that she's passing
it this uh concludes the exec session on
House Bill
4:30 now the chair opens the uh exec
session on House Bill
661 relative to the Department of Health
and Services management of Social
Security payment supplemental
security uh stuff income payments and
veterans benefits for children in foster
care
and that would be on 661 and that would
be the chair recognizing representative
coren for a motion please uh I would
like like to make a motion of OTP on HB
661 and do we have a second over here we
representative
Raymond you know I have not missed your
hand this entire term no this moving
helped representative Ken would you wish
to speak to your motion please thank you
chairman I will
try um I believe that HP 661 is in the
best interest of the child um this bill
is specific to those who are
um awarded money from the state um the
in the past DCF has been taking that
money um this bill hopes to put that
money back into the child's hands once
that child ages out of foster care this
this could be huge for foster kids who
are just starting their life it could be
mean it could mean you know being able
to buy their own their first car or even
put down first and last on an apartment
money anyone else wish to speak on this
representative
deimon thank you Mr
chairman this money belongs to these
kids it's a no-brainer it's their money
so why shouldn't they have it so I I
don't I've never understood why we would
even contemplate keeping it from them um
no child who does not receive social
security has to pay back the foster care
system why does a child who does receive
Social Security have to pay back the
foster care system it seems an inequity
there I'm 100% for this
any further statements in this exec
session on 661 representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to add that um the bill doesn't
mandate that the state save all the
money for the child what it says is that
the state has to consider what the best
application of the money is and I know
when I worked at DCF there were cases
where a child being removed from the
home and that Social Security being
removed from the family meant that the
family could no longer pay their rent
which meant that the kid didn't have a
home to ever come back to and the fact
that that happens is appalling and you
know I I think that um this bill will
solve some of that problem um I would
love to also save money for kids when
they age out I think that's really
important but I also want to maximize
their chances of going home when their
parents Rectify their parenting errors
um and not set the family up for failure
from day one
anyone
else the motion before us on House Bill
661 is ought to pass moved by
representative Coen seconded by
representative Raymond would a clerk
please call the roles chairman Pearson
yes representative D Simone yes
representative
rice representative McMahan yes
representative Nelson yes representative
patno pno sorry yes representative love
here all day get all by the last one
I'll get it representative love yes the
clerk votes yes representative marel yes
representative Greg yes representative
lavesque yes representative rang yes
representative grun yes representative
Raymond representative
georgees yes representative Malone
yes 16 to zero chair calls on the
ranking member for a suggestion would
you like this to go on consent I would
any
objections that doesn't always mean what
it looks like so we will say yes until
somebody above our pay grade says no
okay and uh how long before we can have
the um committee report
why right
now I know I have to look at all I
actually have seen it yeah all right
well I have to sign it though um this
ends the exec session on 661 and now
we're going to go get some hard one a
hard one here and uh we're not going to
do 10 because we want to start after
lunch um we're not going to
285 uh any see what's up uh no we're
going to wait on that one all right
let's let's let's try a hard
one
uh opening H the exact session on House
Bill
652 which is an act to abolish the
Family Division of Circuit Court create
the office of Family
Mediation or yeah and reassign the
jurisdiction of the Family
Division and the chair recognizes Mr
chair the chair recognizes uh uh Jody
you ready to
go or
Lori well they all have both have four
letters all right the check chair
recognizes representative coren for a
motion um on Bill HB 652 I would like to
retain this for
committee the motion is to retain we
have a
second who is the second representative
love and representative coren would you
speak to your motion
please I would like to retain this for
study um because we do recognize that
there are issues within the family court
system um I know that there is the
subcommittee that's already been
presented by chair
Pearson and I would like to um make sure
that this issue specifically is really
looked into and not just brushed
aside anyone else wish to speak
representative Greg I disagree with this
motion only because we do have uh we
already passed or we already have the
subcommittee and also I think that we've
learned anytime that we have a bill that
has a hostile um nature for the courts
it's harder to get cooperation it's
harder to get people in to um testify
and I do think this bill um is
incredibly hostile in nature I actually
think that puts our Cooperative efforts
with the family courts as far as finding
issues and fixing them in Jeopardy so I
would go against this um motion you
would think a proper motion or in your
um belief would be what I think a proper
motion would be itl and I would really
encourage the sponsors of that bill to
come to our sessions and really um learn
all that we get to sess out because we
certainly have made a lot of good um
momentum from our last
subcommittee the um topic of retain
versus itl was one of considerable
discussion in our caucus and
um we see both sides to that so what I
would suggest we do presently is have a
brief discussion as to whether different
ones of you think let's retain it which
does not necessarily mean we have to do
a lot of work on the bill it means we do
a lot of work on the topic which is the
subcommittee or we simply itl it
outright so I'd be interested to see
what other committee members think if
the issue is retained versus
itl hands representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman um just to
reiterate most of what you just said um
this morning morning you identified a uh
committee that will really look into the
court system um if this
bill continues to be what we believe it
is then it's very simple in uh the fall
we our report retention report would
just read that the bill was unnecessary
simple easy
if we find that there may be some issue
that needs to be looked at then I
suppose we could entertain a motion
otherwise but right now I think that
retaining it is for me it's um the
optimal motion anyone else want to weigh
in yes representative L now those of you
from Coos County should know friend this
is
you are good I get both um from many
different people could could you we be a
little bit louder especially the U half
of we yeah um I get both LEC and Le and
Lees
LEC yeah um I have to agree with
representative Greg's point of this is
very hostile towards the family court
system saying that we should just get
rid of it and put it towards back into
the superior your courts hands despite
you know there is some good that they do
yes we know it's this is the worst part
of someone's life they're going through
a divorce they're losing their child
from like all the time to part of the
time or even just holidays depending on
their work schedules and everything it's
a very hard time in that person's life
and to just have you know the superior
court is has a lot on their plate
mediation has a lot on their plate and I
think that putting on those entities
versus having that separate court system
dedicated to the family courts is
definitely very hostile for that and I
don't think that this is a way to go
about that if we do want to bring it
back to the superior court system
so in one word do you suggest itl or
retain I support itl itl okay anyone
else representative love thank you Mr
chair here I'm support and retain for
the for the one reason that we've uh
just established this committee and I'm
expecting that the committee to do great
work and if we come up with with
something that uh that needs rather
expedient uh um attention having this
bill sitting there that we can we can
you know just amend at any time and put
what we need to do right away in it
rather than going before a rules
committee and waiting for non gerain or
gerain Amendment uh
uh decisions uh I I think uh you know
this is uh this is a pretty important
thing that I think we can all agree that
the the the family courts have some some
serious holes in it you know the way we
operate and uh we wouldn't have this
committee if we didn't let's have this
bill sitting there waiting to to amend
with any any ideas we come up with
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that while I
do understand that you know you want to
have a bill at the ready the subcommitte
can also um recommend bills and stuff
one of the things that I have great
pride with in this particular committee
is that we're very intentional about
things we don't hold on to things just
because we want them to kind of like go
hide in the corner and get cobwebs until
we can make them go away later um we've
been incredibly intentional we
understand the Dynamics within the court
systems we have taken great time to hear
from the courts what's going on and
building this relationship having what I
call a threat Bill hanging over in the
side not only goes against everything
that we work for in this committee it
also um really goes against the better
judgment of how we want these
relationships to continue you have said
repeatedly you know we were able to get
lwh hanging fruit I was able to have
something come up we discussed it in
committee and they were already working
on it and now because of that one little
thing not only are they working on the
family courts with communication it is
also has a test program in the Superior
Courts I just I understand the
frustration I and the frustration by the
way is not with everybody it is in our
high conflict cases I am very
sympathetic to that but this doesn't fix
anything putting it in a corner and
making it weight also doesn't fix
anything it just puts us in a situation
where this you know it's kind of this
thing like it's just over there and it
really shouldn't be there like I
strongly think that we should hold to
what we have done in our hard work in
this committee and stick to that anyone
else representative Raymond thank you Mr
sorry thank you Mr chairman um I just I
a lot of the testimony that we've been
hearing about people's um concerns about
the family court have a lot to do with
evidence Rules of Evidence and they have
a lot to do with the lack of the ability
to appeal rulings that they feel were
unfair and I don't see that this bill
improves either one of those things
because now instead of having a judge
we're knocking it down to a mediator
there's nothing in here about how we
will improve evidence or improve the
ability to um have people be able to
appeal their things to something other
than the state you know Supreme Court so
I I think that um there is work to be
done and we've gotten a lot of feedback
to that's starting to create a road map
but I don't think that this bill is a
igned with the feedback that we heard
from the committee last year or even the
testimony on this bill and other bills
which is weird like it it doesn't solve
the problem that we keep hearing is the
problem um and I would love to see a
bill that solves a problem I just I I
need more information still anyone who
has not spoken yet representative
rung a question I noticed that the uh
fiscal note is was this bill was
awaiting a fiscal note from judicial did
I haven't seen it I'm not going to say
it didn't arrive okay all right thank
you representative George thank you Mr
chairman um I think so it's support to
go to the subcomittee because they can
do more research because a small group
can work very uh very well how to
looking for what is going because there
is a problem I can say there is a
problem and the problem we need to fix
it and for that problem to fix it it's
better just go to sub committee than
thank
you representative love thank you Mr
chair um I just need some clarification
uh you know I've heard uh people ask qu
testify that um you know we work nice
with the the family court the family
Court's troubled like we've we've all
said does the family court answer to us
them neither one we are separate
branches of the government which is why
a collaborative attitude is far superior
to the hostile attitude that others
display and we have gained their trust
and vice versa which does not mean we
can tell them what to do but we've
already seen at least one example in the
special committee where they're already
going to work on it before we even had
the subcommittee hearing and there's two
possible reasons for that number one
they fear representative Greg uh or more
likely they've been listening in and
saying oh yeah
that sounds pretty good let's do it so
the uh subcommittee that was just formed
was uh picked by me and for the purpose
of people who play well with other
children and have some knowledge of the
law to continue the tone in the
relationship the special committee had
had with the Judiciary but they don't
report to us and we don't report to them
really do we set the rules or do they
depends on the rules
apparently the rules uh you know from
the all the testimony I've heard the
rules are very broken and we're aware of
that sir very aware of that I I wouldn't
worry about what they feel about it
because it's they're so
broken I am happy that they feel that we
are an asset to them and not an invading
Army and I wish to continue to do that
with them going
forward anybody else on this um either
most and I could support we retain it
and subcommittee continues to do our
work and um we just have this other
thing in the corner or we kill it
outright uh either one will
um work it'll be a little different way
of working it but either one anything
further
um the motion before us is to
retain uh moved by representative coren
and seconded by representative love and
the chair would like to go last on this
would the clerk call the role
please the motion is retained sorry
representative D Simone yes
representative rice yes representative
McMahan yes representative Nelson yes
representative pel yes representative
love yes the clerk votes yes
representative Markle yes yes
representative Greg no
representative LC no representative rang
no Representative grun no representative
uh Raymond no representative Georges yes
no that's going to be nine to was it
10 96 no you you didn't ask the chair
chairman PE well my vote actually
doesn't make any difference um so I'm
going to say yes to retain because it
would have won irrespective of how I
vote so uh the bill is retained 10-6
there is no need of a report it doesn't
go anywhere we keep it in committee
right and we will work on this topic it
is one of two we will begin with and
with that we end the exec session on 652
oh
e
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
make a
motion do I want to do the the
amendment of otpa and I would like to
introduce um an uh Amendment as
such second by rice and please pass the
amendment around um I just want to be
sure uh it is the
695 yes okay
okay what's annoying and this is a
same seven there and I no I'll need one
please sorry I need just one I'm good
okay
well this amendment will replace um all
other amendments that I have had
anything to do with and Mr chairman if I
may I'd like to speak on my Amendment
and show us particularly how this
amendment differs from the previous one
that we have all seen
so the previous amendment that you all
received uh when I introduced the bill
uh has only been changed by um page
two under all parents rights are
reserved and it is the only changes
under
lowercase
a to include to inquire of the school or
School personnel and immediately receive
accurate truthful and complete
disclosure regarding any and all matters
related to their minor child unless an
immediate answer cannot be provided when
the initial request is made in which
case the answer shall be provided no
later than 5 days after the request that
is the only difference between the
we'll give everybody a minute or two to
look at the new Amendment the newest and
lastest Amendment and duly note the
change from the one we previously looked
us and since this amendment 069 five is
a case of amend the bill by replacing
all after the enacting Clause the
original hb10 is should this amendment
be approved old
sir you have a
question representative Ray
uh thank you Mr chairman um so my
question is about procedurally because
there is also another amendment and I'm
curious if we are able to entertain more
than one Amendment at the same time I
know we've had circumstances believe we
have to look at the amendment before us
uh and make a motion accordingly I would
allow the other amendment to be
distributed so you could look at that
but we have to dispose of this motion of
art to pass with Amendment 695 before we
would consider another one so uh
representative Greg if you have copies
of your Amendment or do
we it has it's representative Raymond
and patrino and Greg so if you want to
take a look at that and do a side by
side both of these will be relatively
new to many of us um and go from there
but we do are we able to note that the
amendment uh from representative Raymond
is actually uh mirrored from the Senate
Bill 72 that just passed through their
committee uh I Would S yeah yeah we can
note
it I have an
extra and representative Greg I only
heard part of what you said what is this
amendment from Ray representative raym
Bill 72 their parental Bill of Rights
hb7 s
sp72 the Senate and how did that turn
committee all
right yep have they voted on it on the
floor yet not on the floor yet not on
the floor just how did it come out of
committee Senator it's Senator Langs Bel
it came out of committee
21 um p uh Senator long had some
quibbles with clear and convincing as
these standard of proof uh because that
is not the standard of proof in the uh
child protective act so we we left that
you need evidence and we just crossed
out clear and convincing the only other
change to Senate Bill 72 was
aligning sometimes it said a minor child
sometimes it said their minor child
sometimes it said his or her we simply
changed all of those to his or her minor
child so that they were all the same
yeah it was not controversial
just stylistic R thank you Mr chair um I
noted that in representative Raymond's
Amendment and representative D Simon's
amend uh and and the original bill it
defines parent as parent means a person
who is legal custody of a minor child as
a natural or adoptive parent or legal
guardian but in representative D Simon's
Amendment it defines it as parent means
a person who is the legal natural or
adoptive parent of a minor child and I
know I wasn't here for the hearing but I
I don't know what legal natural
means that seems like that's a change
from the original Bill okay
representative rights to that point okay
anybody to this point if anybody knows
representative
deimon the point to uh the legal natural
or adoptive parent is made because you
can be a bi logical parent and have your
law uh follow up so is that is that term
legal natural defined as that as such in
in another area statute or in in this
area it will
be okay but it's not in the amendment
the legal natural no ma'am okay thank
you so I mean to me that's a flaw of the
amendment because we're using a term
that's not defined thank you for your
opinion representative rice thank you Mr
chairman and with all due respect to my
colleagues across the aisle I'm not sure
why we're amending a Senate bill that we
haven't seen yet if that's something
that needs to be done when when that
Senate Bill comes to us then I would say
we would address it but to amend the
house version to match a Senate bill um
seems redundant almost
I'm it has been offered as a legal house
amendment to this bill where they get
their languages is not the point so in
your opinion no representative Raymond I
would suggest that sometimes what
happens when we have competing bills on
both sides of um the state house is that
we end up having two different things
that pass that don't match each other
and then we have to have a committee of
conference by aligning our bills at an
earli level we avoid that unnecessary
delay especially if we agree in
principle on the matter at hand which is
that parents have rights and they should
be collected in a convenient location um
what the Senate did uh that is different
than what the house bill did was the
Senate did not take up medical records
in this um personally I like that
because we have HB 560 before us this
afternoon which only considers medical
so this would be parents rights and
education and then there would be a
separate bill for parents rights with
medical um and again the who want to
raise productive members of
society and have the rights to
information in order to support the way
they want to raise those children
or educate those children I think this
amendment speaks to all of that and I
think that this Amendment um speaks to
the uh 13 other states that already
have uh a bill such as this and the 32
pending legislations in 32 other
states that is similar to this language
so I think that New Hampshire being the
kind of a state that promotes healthy
families and healthy parents and more
importantly healthy productive children
this amendment I'm hoping uh that you
would understand its necessity and vote
chairman representative
coren thank you Mr chairman um so I love
hb10 as you amended it um I think think
it is more inclusive and more
encompassing than the amendment from
representative Raymond um one thing that
that I love about your amendment is that
it includes the health care
practitioners um I think that as far as
the parents that I talk to um they are
worried about all of their parental
rights so I do like that this bill talks
about that as well um in the in just
glancing at this amendment from
representative Raymond patrino and and
Greg um their amend their Amendment
school or gives medical providers and
out for H for um answering to a parent
um so I think that hb10 as written and
before lunch representative Markel
showed me a document it's the upto-date
parenting plan and he showed it to me in
part because he was noting how the bill
uh and Amendment before us uh track ever
so well with it would you care to speak
to that
sir yes certainly Mr chairman and thank
you for allowing me to address the
issue one of the things that comes out
in parenting plans which are part and
parcel of either unmarried parents
filing parent petitions in court dealing
with their children or divorcing married
parents uh who also have to have
parenting plans in the required pursuant
RSA
461a one of the things that they do is
they include language in there about
information access and sharing and the
basically what the courts are saying is
that you
have the rights to to basically the
information that
um that are being identified for the
most part in um in hb10 the amended
version that we see here um 20250
69h uh so when we look at that that
basically tracks it it summarizes it so
it's kind of interesting because what
the parenting plans are actually saying
is these are the rights you have uh so
this this bill actually puts parents on
notice what they would actually be
getting if they're not in that situation
to begin with and have to go to court to
figure it out so I think that's
important um as it and by way of just
closing comment on it is is that
parenting Liberty interests that you
have under us uh constit under the
federal con under the Constitution as
Federal Constitution as interpreted by
the US Supreme Court and under the New
Hampshire Constitution as interpreted by
the New Hampshire Supreme Court are that
you have a fundamental liberty interest
in raising your children and directing
their care education and so forth
um however the one the limiting factors
are when you go to court or for example
when you go to court and either invite
the state in which you do either by
filing a petition for divorce or
voluntarily inviting the state in by um
filing a parenting petition in the case
of people who aren't married or are you
involuntarily uh are subject to the
state's uh competing interest by
engaging in Acts that are abusive or
neglectful of your children so this I
think serves as a good model and uh to
sum it up it's certainly something I
would
support thank you for allowing me to
address it Mr chairman and thank you any
other comments the motion is on on hb10
is amended by
0695 after this vote the chair will then
recognize a motion for the other
Amendment
0699 any
questions yes representative Greg thank
you Mr chairman specifically on page
four of of the uh dmon Amendment uh the
most recent one page four
um lines 17 and 18 um if you remember so
this did not change I asked in our um
our session on this particularly if this
was just for public schools if that W
and they they said that this was
intended for all schools so I'm just
wondering when we still on line 17 and
18 have the right of a parent to inspect
School District instructional materials
once again this opens this up for any
parent to go after any school including
the home schools including the um um
private schools and say because it
doesn't specify the parent of a child in
that school we now open this up we do
know that we have people that have
traveled to every school board in the
state to request information and stuff
so this is once again a huge um thing
that I I am worried about because this
opens it up to any any of these for any
parent to do it I'm a parent I could
certainly go up to any of the private
schools that even our um own
Representatives have and request
documentation so that's a
worry may I speak to that uh
representative deimon to respond thank
you uh this I specifically put in here
School
District um because whether it be
homeschool
or any other type of school in the
district the district makes the
determination um of the instructional
materials and quite frankly if a parent
is searching for a new home and is
leaving one school district and going to
another school district that parent
should have the right to
um uh inspect that school's School
District's uh instructional materials to
make sure that if they do move to that
District it is a school that would be a
good fit for their family so I
specifically did
not go any deeper than that follow
followup so then um it's fair to say we
are only um making sure that parents
have rights in public schools is that
correct public or private depending upon
she's confused too there is a epidemic
of confusion here anybody who's not
confused who would like to speak it's in
the water I do it is not in the
water representative coren for the
rescue yes um thank you chairman um
don't we as taxpayers have a right to go
to a school district and ask for
curriculum anyway yes and and um if
you're considering putting your child
into a private
school I don't know of any that would
withhold their curriculum from a parent
who was interested in sending their
neither anyone else with a hand up
representative Rong thank you Mr
chairman um I mean aside from the
problem with the defin lack of
definition the one thing I would love to
see in this amendment the and the other
amendment in the Bill is talk more about
parents
responsibilities certainly they have a
right and expectation to participate in
the selection of approval of academic
standards but I think they have a
responsibility too I know it's not going
to be in here but I mean just from the
testimony we heard this morning
regarding child abuse it seems that we
need parents to take as much
responsibility as they do rights so
you you may respond thank you Mr
chairman on uh the very first page under
parental rights and
responsibilities it says they shall have
the same meaning as care custody control
and shall include parenting time
decisionmaking and residential
responsibility parents for whom such
rights to care custody or control of a
child
have been Abridged halted modified or
suspended and shall have their rights
restored upon showing a preponderance of
the evidence that is in the best
interest of the
child I felt that that definition was
enough to um enter into the Bill of
Rights to state that the
parents shall parent their child
followup y uh thank you Mr chairman yeah
I I just think that in I mean this is a
long document and I think that one
section isn't conveyed I think in in my
opinion
to to communicate the important and the
vital role parents have in being
responsible parents um I mean I look
through this I've raised three children
I've always had these rights but what
bothers me is we talk a lot about rights
of parents and I think sometimes we
don't set the expectation of their
responsibility and in some of these
things particularly in in accessing
their medical records um working with
their schools they have a responsibility
I once talked to a father who four or
five months into the school year didn't
even know the building where his child
went to school um I consider that
irresponsible
um it is it illegal no it there's not
going to be anything we find in law that
makes that illegal but I think if we're
going to establish rights we need to put
equal weight into
responsibility thank you as I've often
said um I have been accused on some
occasions of packing too much into a
bill that it should be clean and simple
on one topic if I have more things to
say file another bill and I've been conf
uh accused of the direct opposite so uh
this is the bill we're dealing with
these things representative George thank
you chair U Mr chairman um I'm a little
bit concerned because I saw just a
little bit I've been in school board and
I know what's going inside the school
with the teachers with the kids and a
parent and uh I see lot of parent who
always just sue the school or some
sometime the the kids doesn't even
respect the teacher because the parent
always be over
everything um I think so uh we gave it
just more parent but we don't talk about
how is going to be the relationship for
the kids and the the teacher and the
parents for this bill because this is a
very important for
me representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman um one other concern that I
have is on page two line
25 it specifies that access review to
all medical records um dot dot dot um
the parent is the subject of an
investigation of a crime committed
against the minor child we do know in
this particular committee that when
somebody is under investigation uh about
child abuse it's not under investigation
of a crime so many of many of our child
abuse situations certainly when we're
trying to get interventions for parents
and stuff are within the Civil Court I
certainly know that um in my own
personal EXP experience when my late
husband was being investigated and our
our situation was such that we were
separated for six months he was trying
to get the medical records we were able
to make sure that he couldn't he wanted
to see what had been turned in and in
hindsight it was to to bolster his
criminal case when that got filed but
that is certainly a consideration so
just saying that investigation of a
crime committed that's that's pretty
hard to prove and that's not always
what's going on in abusive cases
unfortunately it is just not in the
criminal it takes a lot to get it into
the criminal court so especially when we
need interventions but it doesn't mean
those parents should be able to access
that medical
reporting representative Mar thank you
Mr chairman for allowing me to address
your concerns uh when that was written
there's a couple of things that need to
be award need to be looked at when we're
talking about privilege and when we're
talking about medical records and people
who treat uh adolescents or other
children there's there's some research
that went into this okay first if
there's going to be Al there's the Civil
aspects of it and then what you're
talking about might be criminal okay as
a general as a general proposition uh
you have a right under under under
basically under the federal and state
constitution you have a right to see
evidence uh that's going to be
introduced against you you know for
example people who commit horrific
crimes particularly against children
that evidence is going to have a right
to be challenged so it wouldn't be
withheld it would be unlikely to be
withheld in the criminal context now
addressing the Civil context which is
where I think you're going with this is
that your is that your real
question can I can I answer so
specifically on letter H so if you look
at line 23 so that's where this so this
is for a parent because we're talking
about parents rights only in this access
and review to all medical records as the
personal representatives of their
children there are many parents who um
for whatever reason are not necessarily
their parental rights have not been
terminated and stuff but they are
separated from their children because of
allegations it doesn't mean that they're
under criminal investigation correct so
that's what I was asking if thank you Mr
chairman for me to address that see so
what happens if you go into the Civil
context which is where I think you were
going with this is is that there's
already case law on point uh I think
we've brought it up before but for a
good a good one to look at is in reberg
okay which is a New Hampshire Supreme
Court case from 2005 where in the middle
of a rather contentious divorce hearing
uh the Supreme Court and this case went
up to the Supreme Court which said that
basically privileged records that
children particularly out of
particularly with uh psychiatric records
or those kinds of things do have
standing to have a privilege asserted
okay now if you're in that kind of
contentious position all right then
somebody is going to have to go to court
and prevent you from getting those
records and that's always almost always
going to be fact dependent okay so you
know almost always I can't see a
situation where it wouldn't be this
would be under normal
circumstances uh so what you actually
are doing here is balancing the rights
of a patient okay against the right of a
parent so for example when personal
representatives for example my research
shows that personal Representatives
under hip ah okay uh actually have the
same standing as the patient themselves
to be able to get records now if we're
talking about abuse or neglect or if
we're talking about allegations where
there are serious
problems and somebody wants records and
they want them for some nefarious
purpose you know then there's room for
intervention so this balances the rights
of you may this balances the rights of
parents and the rights of patients to
have their rights protected you know
people may disagree on that but the
point of it is that's what I think it
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um so I want to go back to page
six uh page
five um at the bottom Roman numeral 2
line
23 um it says except is otherwise
provided by law or core order a health
provider shall not allow a medical
procedure to be performed on a minor
child in its facilities without first
obtaining written parental consent I
want to know where the exception is for
emergency situations um I'm thinking
about our dear friend and colleague
whose child was injured at school and
needed immediate emergent treatment
before she was physically present and
able to sign a consent now there are
other laws allowing those things but
would this require both parents to be
there what if only one parent can be
there how is this going to impact the
daily routine parenting of people where
we frequently when you have two parents
tag off on who's going to do this
appointment and who's going to do that
appointment what if one parent
objects I believe the operative phrase
in 1923 and 26 is uh or excuse me uh 19
and 23 is except as otherwise provided
by law and I'm wondering if our resident
lawyer could expand on that uh thank you
Mr chairman yes I can
uh other statutes provide for you can
dispense with consent for emergency
medical treatment okay so that's as
otherwise provided by law in the case of
Waring parents where they are just at
loggerheads what this requires simply is
parental consent okay so if one parent
consents then that's enough uh and if
you're going to go to court and then if
a parent is wor and we see these
conflicts all the time in court and that
if if a parent is either going to be
orang y or just contentious obstructive
or engaging in some other conduct which
is detrimental to the wellbeing of a
child they're going to have to answer
for
it representative nson thank you Mr
chairman um so in the event of an
emergency in a school setting on page
five line
29 uh says this section does not apply
to Emergency Services pursuant to RSA
1538 col 18 so I think that that would
that thank you
welcome all right the motion before us
is on House Bill
10 with
Amendment
695 and this was moved by representative
uh deimon and seconded by representative
rice that is the
motion 10 with Amendment 695 with the
clerk please call the role want first
yes
first we have
not we are on the adoption of the
Amendments as I uh should have said but
didn't thank
you chairman pi
yes representative D Simone yes
representative rice yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative
panel yes getting better I am
representative representative
love representative cson votes yes
representative marle yes representative
Greg no representative grun
no representative rang no representative
l
no representative Raymond no
Representative georgees no
no
97 97 the amendment passes those of you
who are up on these things do I call do
I call for the next Amendment not now or
amended that's what I thought too and
then we can do another amendment okay
all right uh call on representative D
Simon for a
otpa as amended by 695 as amended by
0695 H okay okay and that was D Simon
and who is the second representative
discussion call the world
please
yes chairman Pearson yes representative
D Simone yes representative rice yes
representative McMahon yes
representative
Nelson yes representative panel yes
represent resentative
love representative coron votes yes
representative marle yes representative
Greg no repres representative LX no
representative r no representative gr no
sorry representative Raymond
Representative georgees no
representative Malone
motion further Amendment a further
Amendment motion on a motion on the
amendment thank you Mr chairman I think
that um I'm trying to decide if it's
worth moving the amendment to have it
fail 7 to9 or if it's worth calling it a
day on this
one would you like few minutes to talk
with Coles thank
[Music]
all
ch
yeah I don't think we need to go into
over
e
because this is split normally I would
just say our committee because I think
that's our power position that we like
to do things as a committee as unanimous
as possible and that's honestly why we
worked on this amendment we understand
that I'm I'm a mama bear to Full Tilt
and to be able to have rights and to
always know that I can go to my child's
School even if she's in a private school
and you know look at the curriculum say
that I don't want her anything is
incredibly important to me it's
incredibly important to all of us um the
reason for this amendment is is that we
saw issues first of all I see an issue
with only targeting kids in public
schools and and making parents who are
in public schools think that you know
they're the only ones that can do that I
think that's a problem I also think that
um not having menacing situations where
we have parents going all over the state
although I do understand about the
moving and stuff I also you know we
looked at this not because we wanted to
copy the Senate bill but because we we
looked at the sponsors on the Senate
Bill we understood that they have the
same heart that they would like to see
parental rights all in one place we also
see that that's a confusion that we
continue to hear not that people I think
we've talked about it over and over that
parents do have rights but the fact that
it's not all in one place that it's not
easy for people to see that's a problem
problem and we hear that and we want to
support that position um in looking at
the Senate bill um certainly it was not
not a democratic bill but we saw that it
had some strengths in it as far as
keeping within the legal tone of um what
we're looking at specifically about the
medical um wanting it not only to
they I think the intention is the same
but I think I know that they had a care
really looking at aligning with the
child protection act I think that was a
big thing I also think that it was a big
deal and I'm probably getting way too
wordy but um it was a big deal also to
align with federal law as far as the
medical part of it um we certainly don't
want something that parents are going to
think that they have and then federal
law is going to pull that back and they
don't actually have that so um this
amendment really speaks to all of those
it also honors the work that we've done
on this committee as a full committee
and understanding that we are for
parental rights and um we know that
there's a need to have it in one place
so I I hope that everyone would consider
this amendment um I think it's a a
strong Amendment and um certainly I
think we could get two houses to agree
on it thank
you I think from my perspective um
having sat on many committees of
conference
um sometimes the good stuff wins out out
and sometimes the stuff that we didn't
do that they did prevails and we do have
another shot at it should this amendment
not pass so it's not the end of the road
on this and I'm glad you articulated it
because I've written some of these
things down and should I get get put on
um a committee of conference I'll
certainly bring our committees at least
part of our committee's uh uh thoughts
on this anybody
else the amendment the motion before us
is the amendment
0699 on House Bill 10 as amended and
passed just a minute ago uh moved by
representative Raymond seconded by
representative Greg the the motion is
ought to pass if you agree with this
amendment you'll vote Yes if you
disagree you will vote no would the
clerk call the role
please chairman pearon no
representative D Simone no
representative rice no representative
McMahon no representative Nelson no
Representative pel
no representative
love I vote no representative Markle
no um representative Greg
yes representative lves yes
representative rung yes
representative grundt yes representative
Raymond representative georgees yes and
representative Malone
yes the motion fails
9-7 so the uh standing motion has been
voted
OTP on House Bill 10 with Amendment
0695 H that has now been uh voted
favorably out of this committee and
representative deimon if you don't have
your blurb ready start
writing it is just in case and uh
yet yeah would you see if we can get it
down here because we're going to be
they may have met in the
morning oh they did okay all righty uh
what have we not done have we not I got
is I open the exec session on House Bill
285 uh this is uh one little line item
focusing on Mental Health as a con
consideration for parenting and the
it my illustrious predecessor
moves what itl itl that is rice and D
Simon and would you please speak to this
certainly HB 285 unfairly singles out
mental health conditions as a factor in
custody decisions without requiring any
evidence that the condition negative
impacts a parents's ability to care for
their child this Broad and vague
language could lead to discrimination
against parents who manage treatable
conditions discouraging indivi
individuals from seeking necessary
Mental Health Care out of fear that the
diagnosis could be used against them and
custody determination should be based on
specific behaviors and the actual
well-being of the child not on
generalized assumptions about mental
chairman first I thought this at first I
thought this would be a good
reminder but then I realized after some
conversation with some judges you know
they really do take this into account
and by separating it out as a special
line item it might point a finger a
little more pointedly than to other
folks so I had an amendment prepared to
soften it um and then came to the
conclusion was persuaded by my caucus uh
members that uh it's really not needed
at best and at worst it could be um
discriminatory so I just wanted to say I
agree with that representative
Raymond oh thank you Mr chairman um I
agree with you also you want to follow
up no can I have um the sheet for The
Minority Report for the previous bill
please sure of
course I should have asked earlier but I
forgot till just
now thank you so much anybody else
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you I know that the
uh Prime sponsor is in the room I do
want to honor the struggle and why this
bill comes about and I do think that we
have other legislation in including
definitions that will really without
calling calling it out directly will
actually help in cases like this so I do
think that we have other legislation um
that is more broad that can cover more
things at once that will actually help
what this situation was trying to help
with representative eimon thank you Mr
chairman uh to Echo some of
Representative Greg's uh sentiments um
we have both been um working on a study
committee to study definitions of uh
certain issues that face
families so I think that rather than
single out one
particular issue I would really rather
work
on issues that can Encompass all
parenting issues uh just because you
have a mental health issue doesn't make
you a person who should not have
parenting rights
I know of a few people who have serious
mental issues and they are absolutely
thoroughly phenomenal parents
however if they were
not the court would
intervene and handle the situation to
keep the kids in a safe environment so
that's why I seconded the
motion further discussion
seeing none the motion before us is itl
on House Bill
285 uh mooved by representative riceon
seconded by representative D Simon will
the clerk please call the role chairman
pearon yes representative D Simone yes
representative rice yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative panel yes representative
love
representative coren yes representative
marel yes representative Greg yes
representative
lest representative rung yes
representative grund yes representative
Raymond representative georgees yes and
representative Malone
yes
160 14 to zero 14 to
what did I first your Ballo yes I'm
sorry I was thinking about it all by
myself and objections to
consent
well
first oh you shall not remain nameless
this uh concludes the exact session on
285 will
miracle okay we do have I think we have
one more have we done
no so we're waiting on a we're not
waiting it's coming but we're going to
do something before then opening the
exact session now on 560 relative to
parental access to minor child's medical
records and representative coren did you
have a motion I would like to motion uh
OTP for H 56 like to move sorry and who
is seconding that uh oh why don't I have
representative rice do that
yeah because you had your hand up uh
now discussion because there will be an
amendment
coming uh from representative Raymond so
why don't we hear from representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman welcome um
so my uh amendment is very minor um
on
uh page well it's only one page on line
19 C of the original it says when a
healthcare provider has determined by
clear en cment ing evidence based on
articulable facts Etc um my Amendment
simply strikes clear and convincing
leaves evidence um and the rest of the
sentence because clear and convincing is
not a part of the child protective
statute so we should be aligning our uh
calling DCF in or you know taking
actions when we're concerned about abuse
or neglect with the child protection
statute and this is the language that
kept the bill from passing the last
couple times it's been up
CH would like to call on representative
Markel because clear and convincing and
preponderance and oh boy do we have the
goods on you and all of those are legal
terms and so uh we'd like to know a
little bit about how line 19 of the
original Bill compares to what's being
suggested here okay well if you're
dealing with the three standards of
proof the top one is a criminal standard
that's beyond A Reasonable Doubt uh that
is a very high hurdle to get over clear
and convincing evidence is used very
rarely in um used very rarely in civil
matters you find it sometimes in
contempt because of the possibility of
incarceration uh well it's true and uh
sometimes for example in other things
like professional discipline uh for
example um in my in the case of an
attorney who's called based on his
conduct uh the the professional conduct
committee has to has before it brings a
a docket a case for example has to
believe that there's a reasonable
possibility that misconduct can be shown
by clear and convincing evidence
otherwise it's a very rarely used
standard preponderance of the evidence
which is basically 51% more likely than
not just get the ball over the net is
the more widely accepted standard so
that might be something you might want
to consider so as a lawyer um who has
dealt with these matters a lot would you
uh think that line 19 of the bill has
determined by clear and convincing
evidence uh should be amended as the uh
representative Raymond suggested sir um
let me just take a look right here okay
that's 493 okay yeah I think it would be
um you think the amendment would be I
would think you would probably need to
align that and uh align that uh um with
yeah so under the child protectant
statute which is RSA 169c it says um
that if a if a mandated reporter has
reasonable cause to suspect that's the
standard of proof by which they would
contact DC yeah I would yeah so in this
case it would say when a healthc care
provider has determined by evidence and
then I left the rest of it based upon
articulable facts so there's still a St
there's still the requirement that the
that the provider has to have a reason
for it it can't just be I have a funny
feeling it has to be articulating that
the child has told me X or I'm saying
that you know the child is covered in
Bruises And if I do this it could result
in further harm that would be it you
know I would I'm not even sure that you
really even need a standard of proof
because that's a legal determination and
what you're doing here is looking at
reporting abuse if do I have that
correct well okay so if you're looking
at a porting
review um you know that's basically a
discretionary judgment and I don't know
too many people outside I don't know too
many people who are going to be able to
articulate exactly what clear and
convincing evidence is uh you know as a
practical matter in the legal profession
I'll call it
75% okay
uh preponderance of the evidence 51% get
the ball over the more likely than not
so I would just say if they've got
reason to
believe then that was what I would make
it right which is what I would have made
that but someone had already put in the
bill upon articulable fact and I thought
well I would like to make the minimum
changes okay necessary okay to satisfy
well then articulable facts would make
sense yep okay so in other words the
answer is so you know Dr so and so or Mr
so and so what did you what led you to
believe that you should make this report
well this this this this this this leads
me to
conclude there you go y so in that case
I would like to move otpa of my
Amendment motion on the floor and once
again the chair is uh a bit confused uh
do we have to do 560 and then we vote
the amendment you have to vote the
amendment vote the amendment first so uh
representative coren and rice would you
withdraw your motions temporarily please
AB absolutely thank you okay now oh okay
um representative Raymond would you make
a motion on your Amendment please thank
you I would like to move that we adopt
amendment
0673 to hp56 and a second representative
Greg well we just heard the arguments
anybody else have anything seeing
nothing uh the motion before us is uh
moving
Amendment 0673
House Bill
um call the
RO
please chairman Pearson yes
representative D Simone yes
representative rice yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative pel yes representative
coren yes representative marel yes
representative Greg yes representative l
oh sorry it was good practice so yes it
was yeah representative rung yes
representative grund yes representative
Raymond representative georgees yes and
140 and now we have a motion
to be made for
[Music]
otpa and that had been representative
Ken you still have your blurb that can
be
tweaked because we always need to say in
a blurb the amendment did such and such
and you can just add a sentence sure so
would you like to make that motion
absolutely please make that motion I
make a motion to move HB 560 TP a no a a
second was former chairman okay good
there we go any further discussion
seeing hearing none uh clerk call the
rooll please the motion is 560 as
amended by 0673 moved by representative
coren seconded by representative Rice go
chairman Pearson yes representative D
Simone yes representative rice yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Pell yes representative coren yes
representative Marco yes representative
Greg yes representative rung yes
representative gr yes representative
Raymond representative georgees yes and
representative Malone yes 14th is there
now would everybody please be quiet
except representative
Greg would you like the sign
I would love one thank you any
objections good uh this concludes the um
exact session on House Bill
560 and uh we'll take a blurb to review
and any other blurbs one from
representative rice when she gets a
chance
now guess what the team comes together
as we often do on I open the exact
session on house Bill 493 and you should
amendment Oh I thought so and hey guess
what the Cher seconds it now
representative Greg would you please
speak to the amendment
0715 on House Bill 493 yes after um
listening to testimony earlier we
decided that to add the entire section
two here so this is um taking out the
part that was just uh taking care of
kids or you know minors or whatever else
so that way we could include this and
make sure that um this is just part of
the accredited the continuing education
because we do understand how important
it is to get this child abuse education
out
there and you have also Chang in line
five to put this all under continuing
medical education yes that came up too I
forgot about that part too yes we
changed the statute
mhm but I do think that is it is
important to because we this language
has been out there even though you know
I understand with the medical
association you know they would like to
handle this unfortunately we've not seen
them moving to do that at a at a greater
at a great number that I would like to
see so I think based on the successful
implementation of legislation on this in
other states I would um I think that
this is the right step for New Hampshire
and to my point about how this could
open the flood dat gates to all kinds of
people wanting an hour for this and an
hour for that I am
persuaded that child abuse being such a
very important topic and such a
widespread thing would not necessarily
open the floodgates that we could say to
people coming with other things that
happens once in a million times I'm
sorry this does not rise to the level of
that so I am in effect withdrawing my um
objection here and U saying how much I
appreciate how the team as we often do
came together anybody else oh
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that thank
you for being open I really appreciate
very much it means a lot to me um last
year uh when this bill was heard I I'm
going to get choked up I can't I really
can't barely talk about this there W um
there was a doctor who um thank you who
uh testified about non-ambulatory
infants who had been seen with bruising
and then came back either dead or will
live in a vegetative state for the rest
of their lives and um I just could not
shake that um and so I'm really glad
that we were able to come to compromise
on this and again thank you Mr chairman
for your willingness to be open
representative Pano we can go home to
our spouses tonight and say honey we
have not added one more hour to your
burden do you wish to speak yes thank
you I just want like to clarify thank
you Mr chairman um this now would apply
to all Physicians regardless of what age
thank
you old Physicians young Physicians yeah
depending on age
now representative D Simon thank you Mr
chairman I think that what concerned me
was when one of the Physicians testified
today and in the beginning of his
testimony stated that there are many
Physicians who notice things but they're
so rushed they don't want to stop and
take the time well maybe if they had
this
education they would understand that is
integral to the life of a child that
they stop and take the time even though
they are already mandated reporters they
need to
learn how to stop and take the time I
get that they're rushed I get that
they're busy I bless them all so that's
why I'm I'm happy to vote for this I had
a rather naughty thought here um at the
medical center I supervise if the
patient needs 26 minutes and the
insurance reimburses for 15 the patient
gets 26 minutes and for those doctors
and I know many of them who are told you
will spend 15 minutes then go to the
next room I can see a um a rebuttal here
to being rushed along when they see
clear and present danger signs here that
said yes I spent 18 minutes do you wish
to discipline me bring it on so you know
I am very fed up with the state of
medical as the insurance companies have
hijacked it so um I I don't think I need
to make that as in a form of emotion I
think that's acclamation anyone else yes
representative coren thank you Mr
chairman um that's not what I got from
the story I got that the physician wrote
it down knowing he was seeing abuse but
didn't want to get involved and to me
that's a whole another can of wors needs
to be dealt with
that is different I think it's also a
valid point yeah anyone else
representative Rong thank you Mr
chairman the other thing that becomes
clear with this amendment is that
because it applies to all Physicians not
those who just treat um patients under
the age of 18 is that it may help
Physicians who may not be seeing that
the victim of child abuse to be able to
recognize that it may exist because of
how they may be treating a parent or a
sibling or a caregiver so I think having
all Physicians more aware of the
reporting and signs of child abuse it
may help children who that particular
physician may not be seeing or that
nurse prti nurse practitioner physician
an excellent point I've just asked the
clerk to make sure that's been put in
the minutes that's a very good point
anybody
else okay the motion before us I believe
is the
amendment 0715
moved by representative Greg second and
by the chair would the clerk please call
the role chairman Pearson yes
representative D
Simone yes representative rice yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Pell yes representative coren yes
representative marel yes representative
Greg
yes representative uh rung yes
representative grund yes representative
Raymond yes representative georgees yes
nothing
y now for your continuing
education why did representative Greg
not ask if this should go on
consent representative Rong for the
answer because it was only a vote on the
amendment not otpa
brilliant
now who wants to make the motion and
write the
blurb and defend at all
well you know if there was somebody who
was way more enthusiastic I would pick
on
them and you're going to do what no I'll
try to be second but
you're okay we we passed the love around
you know that representative rice moves
and
representative gorgeous G georgees
gorgeous still je still jealous of the
hair still jealous
and the motion before us is otpa on
House Bill 493 is amended by
0715 mov by rice Mo seconded by georgees
and the clerk may call the role please
chairman Pearson yes representative D
Simone yes representative rice yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Pell yes representative coren yes
representative marel yes representative
Greg yes representative rung yes
representative grund yes representative
Raymond yes representative georgees yes
representative Malone
yes
140 would I like to do what now oh
consent yeah okay all right thank you
any objection of course not and and I
just want to say to representatives
grund and rung and peternell you're
welcome anytime and you can even sit up
here but you got to make somebody sick
to do it so thank you for coming we so
enjoyed you and uh we're the we're the
fun
kids
what okay oh I also have to end conclude
the EXE session on 493 remember no
school next Tuesday and we finish up two
weeks from now and so be ready be
happy and we are done thank you does
rep